bonjour à tous je vous propose ce matin
d'écouter le début des auditions de la
commission d'enquête sénatoriale sur la
société ecomov une commission d'enquête
demandée et obtenu par les sénateurs
socialistes alors eomov c'est cette
société chargée de la de l'écotaxe poids
lourd une collecte pour laquelle la
société devrait gagner à peu près 250
millions d'euros par an un montant jugé
exorbitant par les sénateurs de la
majorité qui ont donc demandé la
création de cette commission d'enquête
alors ces audition devrait se dérouler
au pas de charge et se terminer d'ici la
fin du mois de janvier avant des
déplacements des sénateurs prévus en
Europe voilà tout de suite je vous
propose donc d'écouter le début de ces
auditions
bon mes chers collègues nous allons
commencer notre nous commençons donc
notre programme
d'audition en entendant aujourd'hui des
représentants de la société ecomov SAS
je vous précise que cette audition est
ouverte au publque et à la presse
qu'elle fera l'objet d'une captation
vidéo retransmise en direct sur le site
du Sénat ainsi que d'un compte rendu
publié donc nous accueillons le
président des comomou monsieur
Dani accompagné de son vice-président
Monsieur Michel
couril sont également
présents interviendront dans le dans le
débat monsieur Sergio batibol batiboya
pardon Antoine
Capu et Michelangelo Damasco vous êtes
tous les trois membres du comité
exécutif et puis sont également présents
d'autres membres du comité exécutif mais
qui sont juste présents et
n'interviendront pas dans le dans le
débat je vous rappelle messieurs que
conformément au termees de l'article 6
de l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relette fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires votre audition doit se
tenir sous sererment je vous rappelle
également qu'en cas de faux témoignage
les personnes entendues sont pass cibles
des peines prévues par les articles 434
13 434 14 et 434 15 du code pénal donc
je vais vous demander messieurs ceux qui
intervenaient les cinq personnes qui
interviennent vous allez prêter serment
de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité et à au nom de quand je vous
appellerai je vous demanderai donc de de
vous lever de lever la main droite et de
dire je le jure d'accord on va commencer
par le Président Monsieur Daniel
mi j Monsieur Michel
Cornil monsieur Sergio batiboard je jure
Monsieur Antoine Capu je le jure et
Monsieur Monsieur michelangeloasco Je je
vous remercie beaucoup euh je vous donne
maintenant si vous voulez bien la parole
pour un exposé liminaire qu'on va fixer
selon la tradition à une quinzaine de
minutes hein euh à la suite duquel le
rapporteur Virginie Cless et les autres
membres de la commission vous poseront
des questions moi-même je compléterai
éventuellement donc vous avez dû vous
répartir la tâche entre vous vous avez
15 minutes au global en grosso modo
voilà puis ensuite chacun de vous pourra
répondre comme vous le souhaiterez aux
différentes questions posées je vous
donne la parole euh merci euh madame la
président madame la rapporteur euh
madame messieur les sénateurs et Madame
monessieur tur je tiens à vous remercier
de nous donner l'opportunité de nous
exprimer devant votre commission je
m'excuse pour les moncitat des Français
et donc euh pour la clarité des débats
et pour vous app porter les éléments de
la plus grande clarité je suè de passer
après la parole à les président Michel
Cornil qui donnera pr de notre
testimonage merci madame la présidente
Madame la rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames et
messieurs nous tenons d'abord à vous
remercier de nous donner l'opportunité
de nous exprimer devant votre commission
cette cette audition va nous permettre
d'expliquer de clarifier de préciser
certaines
informations qui pour certaines nous
considérons qu'elles sont erronnées des
informations qui ont été diffusées au
cours de ces derniers mois qui ont été
extrêmement riches au niveau de
l'actualité sur
l'écotax en effet depuis le mois de
novembre le projet et ses acteurs ont
fait l'objet d'un certain nombre
d'attaques que pour certaines nous
considérons comme
infondé cette attitude a
déstabilisé les
salariés qui travaillent sur ce projet
qui représente environ un millier de
personnes quand nous prenons les
salariés propres des comov mais
également ceux des sous-traitants et des
autres entreprises qui travaillent
depuis maintenant de nombreux mois sur
ce
projet ce
projet c'est grâce aux efforts d'ecomove
et de ses fournisseurs qu'aujourd'hui et
je pèse mes mots le dispositif est
prêt et que les tests qui ont été
réalisés montrent qu'il fonctionnent
correctement la marche à blanc qui s'est
déroulé sur la base du volontariat elle
s'est déroulé depuis la fin juillet
jusqu'à la fin novembre donc une période
relativement longue a concerné 10000
poids
lourds il y a eu plus de 100 millions
d'éléments de tarification c'est-à-dire
d'événements
ponctuels qui ont été observés et ceci a
donné lieu à
27000 détail de liquidation alors je je
traduis détail de liquidation ce sont
les facture détaillé comme on pourrait
dire dans un langage peut-être plus
commun là on est sur un langage qui est
propre à l'administ notamment des
douanes donc tous ces
chiffres je les cite car ils sont
conforme aux attendus et
aujourd'hui notre système est
homologué et il est prêt à fonctionner
c'est-à-dire à collecter
l'écotaxe nous souhaitons aussi profiter
de ce propos
liminire pour revenir sur la procédure
d'appel d'offre qui a conduit l'État à
sélectionner notre société
ecomove en avril
2009 l'État français a lancé un avis
d'appel à à
concurrence l'écotaxe po lourd je me
permets de faire ce rappel j'en ferai
pas beaucoup mais celui-ci me semble
important s'inscrit dans un cadre
législatif et communautaire très précis
la loi du 3 août 2009 dite loi du Grenel
1 prévoit dans son article 11 je le cite
une écotaxe sera prélevée sur les poid
lourds à compter de 2011 à raison du
coût d'usage du réseau routier national
métropolitain non concédé et des voies
des collectivités
territoriales susceptible de subir un
report de trafic cette écotaxe aura pour
objet de financer les projets
d'infrastructure notre société ecomove a
été choisie au terme d'un procédure de
dialogue
compétitif que l'on pourrait qualifier
d'assez longue puisqu'elle a duré 21
mois tout au long de ce
processus le dialogue entre l'État et
les différents candidats qui avaient été
sélectionnés a été a été
particulièrement
intense je vous donnerai quelques
quelques petits chiffres il y a d'abord
eu une phase d'échange préliminaire
entre octobre et novembre 2009 il y a eu
neuf sessions d'échanges entre les mois
de mars et les mois de mai
2010 et ensuite une période de
clarification des offres en octobre et
en novembre
2010 ce dialogue a été mené du côté de
l'État par la mission de tarification de
la DGITM DGITM direction générale des
infrastructures des transports et de la
mer et de notre côté les
l'interlocutaire était austral
autostrade excusez-moi pitalia candidat
sélectionné par l'État cette société
étant assisté par un certain nombre de
sociétés françaises je l'ai citeré SFR
SNCF Steria
Talès je peux tout de suite no que c'est
ces 5 sociétés qui constitueront
ultérieurement la société ecomov et qui
rentreront à son
capital la tributaire a donc été désigné
en février
2011 et le contrat a été signé avec
notre société la société de projet
ecomov le 20 octobre 2011 donc sélection
février signature du contrat octobre
2011 pendant cette période et au terme
d'une procédure de recours initiée par
un concurrent il y a eu une prise
d'osition du Conseil d'État qui a jugé
l'ensemble de cette procédure
conforme ce jugement est en date du 24
juin
2011 pour remporter cette appel d'offre
ecomov a développé une solution unique
innovant
que nous tenons à vous présenter
succintement bien évidemment les
questions enrichiront cette présentation
succinte sur le plan technique ecomou va
proposer une solution adaptée à la
capillarité du réseau taxable et à son
extension potentielle avec un nombre
important on pourra vous citer les
chiffres si vous le souhaitez un nombre
important de section de
tarification elle est basée sur une
technologie de localisation
satellitaire qui détecte les
franchissements par les points lourds de
points de
tarification il n'y a donc pour cette
collecte de renseignement aucun
équipement physique nécessaire à
implantter sur le
terrain cette solution est également
très adaptée aux caractéristiques et au
nombre de véhicules assujettis au
paiement de la
taxe pour
dispositif et satisfaire aux obligations
du contrat et a fait appel à des
sous-traitants parmi lesquels
majoritairement ses actionnaires comme
il est habituel d'ailleurs dans ce genre
de
projet pour satisfaire la directive
européenne sur
l'interopérabilité l'État a prévu
l'accès du DISP l'accès au dispositif
puisse se faire par l'intermédiaire de
société habilité au télépéage sous le
sigle SHT société habilité au TPH ecomov
a donc passé des contrats de service
avec toutes celles qui ont souhaité
commercialiser le service écotaxe poids
lourd concernant maintenant le
financement du projet des prêts ont été
souscrits auprès de H établissements
bancaires français et
internationaux pour un montant supérieur
à 500 millions d'euros
enfin je soulignerai ce point ecomov a
accepté de prendre à sa charge les
risques liés bien évidemment au missions
qui lui sont confiées mais également la
plupart des risques relatifs aux
évolutions de l'environnement pendant la
période
d'exploitation sur ces bases
ecomo s'est engagé dans un contrat de
partenariat à fournir à l'état le
dispositif relatif à l'écotaxe poids
lourd et à l'exploiter pendant une durée
de 11 ans et
demi il nous semble important de
souligner que l'offre proposé par
ecomour était la moins coûteuse des
propositions reçues par l'État notre
système est également très compétitif si
on le compare à d'autres projets et je
prendrai une référence qui est souvent
citée qui est celle de
l'Allemagne en effet ce système est
moins performant que celui que nous
avons développé en TER de valeur ajoutée
pour l'État et il est non
interopérable le prix payé par l'État
allemand à la société de collec est plus
de deux fois supérieur à celui payé à
l'état français alors que le nombre de
kilomètres et de V et de véhicules à
contrôler sont
comparables en
conclusion nous avons une grande
confiance dans le dispositif que nous
avons mis en
place conçu et régalisé dans le cas d'un
véritable partenariat avec l'État il est
le fruit d'un dialogue constant avec le
ministère des Transports et avec les
douanes il répond aux exigences
techniques fonctionnelles légales
formulé par l'État il est dors déjà en
opération pour une partie importante
depuis le mois de juillet
2013 cette partie importante je donne
quelques détails l'enregistrement des
redevables le site internet les système
d'information et d'assistance le centre
d'appel le réseau commercial nous tenons
à vous remercier de votre attention et
nous restons bien évidemment à votre
disposition pour toutes vos questions
merci Monsieur le vice-président je vais
don la parole à madame le rapporteur
Virginie Cless
oui merci madame la Présidente et merci
pour cet exposé liminire à la fois clair
et et et concis qui n'empêche pas bien
évidemment qu'il y ait qu'il y ait des
questions euh supplémentaire euh ma
première question va concerner peut-être
la chronologie de la formation du
consortium euh est-ce que vous pouvez
nous éclairer à ce sujet et nous dire
précisément à quel moment du dialogue
compétitif ou à quel moment de la
procédure euh sont entrer dans le
capital de la société autostrade SFR
Tales et cetera pour pour former le
consortium ecomove euh quelles ont été
aussi les positions prises par les les
représentants de l'État français pour ce
qui concerne notamment Thalès et la
SNCF puisque l'État français est
représenté au sein du conseil
d'administration de ces deux sociétés
donc quelles ont été les positions
prises par les représentants de l'État
français au conseil d'administration
ainsi que par le commissaire au
gouvernement et le contrôleur pour
l'État pour l'État
français pouvez-vous aussi nous nous
dire à votre sens euh de votre point de
vue à vous ce qui justifie un contrat de
partenariat public privé sur un projet
qui associe à la fois de
l'investissement technique dans les
dispositifs dont vous nous avez parlé et
l'affermage d'une
taxe c'est quand même quelque chose
d'assez innovant et qui n'est a priori
pas adapté à un contrat de partenariat
public privé d'ailleurs ça a été dit à
plusieurs reprises dans dans les
documents que j'ai que j'ai consulté
contrat partenariat public privé à
priori c'est plutôt euh investir sur de
l'immobilier et assurer après
l'entretien le fonctionnement et cetera
de l'immobilier l'affermage d'une taxe
est quand même très très loin du
fonctionnement ou de l'entretien d'un
immeuble quel qu'il soit euh est-ce que
vous pouvez aussi nous expliquer euh sur
votre installation physique en Mosel
comment est-ce que ça s'est passé de
façon précise est-ce que vous avez
acheté des bâtiments est-ce que vous
avez acheté du foncier à quel prix
avez-vous acheter pour quelle surface de
plancher savez-vous il s'agit de
bâtiment ou de de fonciers appartenant à
la défense si je ne ne m'abuse donc
savez-vous si la meraille la mission
pour la réalisation des actifs
immobiliers de la défense a ou n'a pas
fait un projet de restructuration des
des locaux de ou du foncier que que vous
occupez ou si ça été fait par la mission
de restructuration de de la défense euh
est-ce que ça a été acheté de gré à gré
ou est-ce que ça a été mis aux enchères
ou selon quelle procédure donc est-ce
que vous avez acheter ces bâtiments
savez-vous si ils étaient s'il
relevaient encore du domaine public et
dans ce cas-là quelle a été la procédure
suivie et où peut-on la retrouver pour
déclasser ces C ce foncier ou cette
immobilier du domaine du domaine public
et pour revenir au problèm enfin au
problèm aux questions qu'on peut se
poser autour de de la
taxe vous êtes-vous interrogé ou
avez-vous des réponses ou ù n'en
avez-vous pas au jour
d'aujourd'hui
sur la façon dont peuvent se passer le
relever des
infractions et le recouvrement des
éventuelles amendes parce que si j'ai
bien compris aujourd'hui la façon dont
il est prévu que cela fonctionne il y a
d'abord le préfet qui a compétence pour
agrémenter les agents qui vont être
chargés du recouvrement et du contrôle
or le préfet a d'abord une compétence
départemental et et là le le le
recouvrement euh de la taxe se fera
généralement au siège deentreprise
concerné alors que le constat
l'infraction sera un peu partout sur le
territoire national donc c'est ça me
semble un petit peu un petit peu
incohérent euh d'une part d'autre part
pourquoi est-ce que c'est le préfet qui
a récupéré cette compétence alors que ça
devrait relever des compétences des
douanes comment est-ce que ça va se
passer pour les infractions euh commises
par des sociétés étrangères euh et
comment va se passer la poursuite des
infractions parce qu'une fois de plus si
j'ai bien lu et si j'ai bien compris
eomou va être responsable y compris du
recouvrement des infractions et et de la
taxe et comment vont faire les agents
des Comou pour arrêter des camions pour
vérifier s'ils ont si non pas le
dispositif dans dans le camion comment
va-t-on s'organiser de façon très
pratique pour que ce soit la même
personne à priori un agent des forces de
sécurité française donc la même personne
qui constate action et qui dresse le PV
je ne vous cache pas et tout le monde le
sait ici il y a eu quelques
contestations avec les radar
électronique où il fallait que ce soit
la même personne le même agent qui
constate l'infraction et qui dresse le
PV ça a provoqué un certain nombre
d'annulation est-ce qu'on ne se dirige
pas droit vers ce genre de de problème
et puis euh peut-être en dernière
question pour l'instant sur cette
première salve euh j'ai vu dans mon
dossier là que j'avais les j'avais les
les CV des des personnes qui sont ici et
son sans doute d' un certain nombre
est-ce que vous pourriez nous fournir
l'organigramme un organigramme plus
détaillé des cadres et des dirigeants de
echomove avec l'ensemble de leur CV s'il
vous plaît voilà et puis je m'arrête là
pour
l'instant bien merci Madame
euh bon je je je vais répondre en
prenant l'ordre de vos questions étant
entendu que sur le dernier point
l'organigramme ça ne pose aucun problème
on vous le fera parvenir vous fera
parvenir dans les dans les jours qui
viennent je ne pense pas que c'était de
ce point de vue-là une question
euh alors la la société ecomov a donc
été
constituée pour la signature du contrat
c'est-à-dire que pendant toute la phase
du dialogue compétitive comme je vous
l'ai indiqué dans mon exposé minaire
c'était autostrade pitalia qui candidat
désigné par l'État avait mené les
négociations assisté par des partenaires
qui étaient potentiellement les
actionnaires de l'entreprise le contrat
ayant été attribué la société ecomove a
été constituée en société de projet
c'est une société anonyme simplifiée au
capital de 30 millions d'euros qui a été
constitué par autostrade à hauteur de 70
%
par alors attendez que je retrouve mes
notes par Thalès à hauteur de 11 % par
la NCF à hauteur de 10 par Steria à
hauteur de 3 et par SFR à hauteur de 4
%. 6 6 % voilà je pense que de mémoire
la somme doit faire 100 %
euh c'est donc cette société qui
euh s'est vu transférer des
obligations qui avaiit été négocié et
qui
euh ont donc donnait lieu à la signature
du contrat alors vous avez souligné tout
à l'heure que deux de ces sociétés
avaient comme actionnariat l'état euh à
ma connaissance je n'ai jamais eu
entendu parler de difficulté de ce point
de vue
euh
peut-être peut-être que le représentant
de Thalès d'ailleurs pourra forcément
pas forcément d'une difficulté savoir
comment ça s'est passé simplement et
quelles ont été les positions prises par
les représentants de l'ét français oui
peut-être qu'on pourrait rappeler le
rôle de chacun d'eux
Talès SNCF et cetera quels étaient leurs
voilà l'objet de leur participation
qu'est-ce qu'ils apportai pourquoi ils
étaient là VO voilà vous voulez qu'on le
fasse tout de suite ou oui bon ben
peut-être que Monsieur Capu qui euh oui
madame la rapporteur je je vais
reprendre votre question initiale car je
crois qu'elle est plus précise que la la
réponse qui vous a été apportée de façon
liminire par euh le vice-président
Cornil vous avez souhaité savoir comment
SFR Steria et SNF et Talès on rejoint
autostrade pour former
ecomov si l'on reprend l'historique de
notre projet ces sociétés ont apporté
leur contribution à autostrade en tant
que sousraitant dès le dépôt de l'offre
initiale c'est-à-dire dès le 7 janvier
2010 ces sociétés ont par la suite
accompagné autostrade sous ce statut
pendant toute la durée de la procédure
jusqu'à la signature du contrat de
partenariat le 20 octobre
2011 à ce sujet il convient de rappeler
que le règlement de la
consultation presrivait que le 10
contrat de
partenariat soit signé par une société
de projet qui est donc
eomove c'est-à-dire une société
spécifiquement créée par la tributaire
de la consultation en vue de l'exécution
du contrat de
partenariat c'est la raison pour
laquelle autostrade attributaire du
contrat a créé en février 2011 une
filiale donc la société Comou SAS afin
qu'elle devienne la société de projet
exécutant le contrat de
partenariat il est tout à fait usuel
dans ce type de projet que les contre
les contributeurs principaux de la
construction et de l'exploitation du
dispositif soi conduit à prendre une
participation dans la société de projet
parce que c'est en effet un moyen
extrêmement efficace de renforcer les
liens entre toutes les parties pour
l'exécution du contrat et ainsi
d'assurer les meilleures chances de
succès au
projet conformément à ce qui était prévu
dans l'annexe 4 du règlement de la
consultation complémentaire numéro 4
autostrade a annexé dans son offre les
principaux termes et conditions des des
sous-contrats prévus en phase de
conception réalisation et d'exploitation
maintenance avec les sociétés
sous-traitantes SFR stia
sncfn etalè ainsi que les informations
concernant les évolutions prévues à
l'actionnariat de la société de
projet ces modifications ont pris effet
le 26 octobre
2011 qui est la date à
laquelle ces quatre sociétés ont pris
une participation dans la société de
projets ecomov SAS et ont signé les
annexes du contrat de partenariat qui
concernent des éventuels nouveaux
actionnaires à la société de projet ces
annexes étant pour être parfaitement
complet et précis l'annexe numéro 36 qui
concernait la stabilité du capital de la
société et l'annexe numéro 42 qui concit
la promesse de cession d'action que
faisaient les actionnaires de la société
de projet au cas où l'État aurait
souhaité racheter la
société donc en conclusion de cette
historique qui replace donc
le les positionn successifs des
sous-traitants devenus actionnaire de la
société
ecomove je souhaite réattirer votre
attention comme l'a fait le
vice-président Cornille dans son exposé
liminaire sur le fait
que toute toute cette séquence et toute
cette procédure a fait l'objet d'un
examen très attentif et d'une validation
par le Conseil d'État dans sa décision
du 24 juin
2011 alors maintenant pour venir sur le
rôle
précis des
sociétés actionnaires de la
sociétécomov seria tout d'abord est en
charge de la mise en œuvre des systèmes
centraux de gestion financière et
technique ainsi que du système de
Relation Client de la société Comou
c'est le véritable cœur de
l'architecture
informatique le système de gestion
financier assurera la gestion de comptes
et la facturation des
redeva la gestion de la comptabilité de
la taxe la gestion logistique des flux
d'équipement marqués sur le réseau de
distribution la supervision du
fonctionnement du dispositif dans son
ensemble la construction des
statistiques et des indicateurs de
performance et la gestion des échanges
avec les partenaires
externes Steria assurera par
ailleurs toute la pendant toute la durée
du contrat de partenariat l'hébergement
et l'exploitation informatique de la
totalité du système d'information de la
société
ecomov SFR met à disposition ces réseaux
de communication et sa maîtrise de
l'ensemble des services de
télécommunication fixes et mobiles
requis par le système d'écotaxe par la
solution technique écotax pour les poids
lourds et c'est faire propose notamment
une solution qu'on appelle Machine to
Machine pour les équipements
embarqués euh le groupe SNCF assure par
l'intermédiaire de G en sous-traitance
d'comov la logistique des équipements
embarqués distribués par ecomove donc
leur stockage leur distribution et
cetera ainsi que les opérations de
maintenance terrain grâce aux
compétences techniques et à la
couverture nationale des équipes de la
branche et NCF
infra et ce travail de sous-traitance
des infrastructures de terrain est
effectué lui en sous-traitance de
Thalès Talès pour terminer est le
fournisseur du système de contrôle des
véhicules assugjéti il comprend donc
l'ensemble de la solution de contrôle
automatique fixe ou déplaçable poids
lourd qui est réalisé donc sur
663 point du réseau routier le contrôle
manuel mobile équipant les véhicules de
contrôle essentiellement des douanes et
le contrôle manuel les outils de
contrôle manuel portable destinés aux
agents le système également Talès
fournit le système de supervision
technique et le centre de traitement des
anomalies qui sont propres au système de
contrôle et par ailleurs Thalès
contribue également à la conception de
la solution de positionnement
satellitaire ainsi qu'à la sécurité
globale du système écotax voilà quels
sont les euh euh
les missions les responsabilités affecté
aux quatre actionnaires qui ont rejoint
autostrade alors autostrade quant à lui
a et et le fournisseur du système de
collecte y compris donc l'ensemble des
équipements embarqué destiné au redeva
non abonnés et au SHT qui travaill nous
aurons l'occasion d'y revenir selon
l'option dite option numéro 1 autostrade
est également le fournisseur de tous les
ouvrage civil et métallique pour le
système de contrôle donc les portiques
qui sont déployés sur les points de
contrôle automatique fixe euh ainsi que
euh le réseau de distribution donc qui
comprend l'ensemble des points de
vente de type guichet avec du personnel
ainsi que la fourniture des bornes
automatiques qui permettent donc au
redevable assugéti de se procurer euh de
façon extrêmement aisée l'équipement
embarqué dont ils ont besoin pour
circuler sur le réseau taxé
autostrade assure également
l'intégration du dispositif global et la
maîtrise d'œuvre d'ensemble de
l'opération voilà le rôle de chacun des
acteurs dans la société
ecomov donner la parole à madame le
rapporteur mais juste je voudrais que
vous nous précisiez simplement pour
autostrade si vous aviez déjà une
expérience en matière de recouvrement
des cotaxes est-ce que vous l'aviez déjà
fait avant d'avoir répondu à l'offre de
l'État français ensuite brinie va
prendre la
suite alors oui première chose il faut
rappeler qu'autostrade en Italie un
concessionnaire du réseau autoroutière
très important c'est qu' autostrade en
Italie il collecte un péage c'est pas
une taxe sur un réseau euh de autour des
3000 km euh des d'autoroute concédé en
Italie et il fait la même chose dans des
autres pays à niveau mondial euh pour
venir plus proche à l'expérience
français euh autostrade toujours à
travers un appel d'offre international
euh a remporté euh une un projet en
Autriche qui était réalisé entre l'année
2002 et 2004 euh qui est à des
similarités très importants avec les
systèmes Français au-delà qu'il s'agit
pas d'une taxe mais la partie taxe
intervient plutôt dans la dans les cadre
juridique qui s'applique au traitement
du point de vue technique l'ffet qu'il
s'agit d'une taxe d'un péage
n'intervient pas forcément dans le
système et autostrade a mise en place
euh un projet des péages multivvoie euh
sans arrêt de véhicule euh pour des
poids lourds euh des poids supérieur à
3,5 ton en Autriche sur un réseau euh
des 2000 km ça c'étit 2002 2003 il est
rentré en exploitation le 1er janvier
2004 et il est toujours en exploitation
ainsi que les système et la société sont
été
euh euh reprises par l'État autrichien
et intégré au sein de la concessionnaire
d'autoroute autrichienne qui est une
société
publique
oui merci merci pour ces pour ces
précisions et pour continuer un petit
peu sur sur cette sur ce thème
pouvez-vous nous préciser qui sont les
actionnaires de
d'autostrate aujourd'hui euh pouvez-vous
aussi n nous redire pour autostrat
l'importance dans sa stratégie
commerciale de ce contrat par rapport à
à la suite des événements est-ce que
c'était vraiment primordial ou est-ce
que c'était un projet parmi d'autres par
que c'était juste un un projet
intéressant et quels sont les arguments
que vous avez utilisé ou que vous
utiliseriez aujourd'hui pour nous
convaincre que le choix de la de la
technique hein donc le le le choix du du
du repérage et de la du calcul grâce à
la technique de la taxe du par les
transporteurs est meilleur que le
déclaratif d'autant plus que la
répercussion de la taxe se fait elle se
fera en tout cas c'est ce qui est
aujourd'hui dans dans dans les texes sur
la base du déclaratif donc quel est
l'intérêt comment pourriez-vous nous
convaincre de l'intérêt d'investir
énormément dans de la technique pour
calculer la taxe du à partir du moment
où la répercussion vers le chargeur se
fera sur le mode du
déclaratif alors qui veut
répondre madame excusez-moi et et
j'insiste aussi un tout petit peu est-ce
que vous pourriez aussi nous fournir les
délibérations des conseils
d'administration ou les demander à vos
actionnaires donc SNCF une fois de plus
et Thalès qui ont acté l'entrée de SNCF
et de Thalès dans les dans le capital
d'comove alors monsieur damascou qui
répond euh oui je
madame je vous précise que le seul
actionnaire d'autostrade et atlana spa
qui est euh une société
euh côté à la Bourse de de Milan l'un
des des plus importants euh Atlantia euh
est une société dont la majorité la
majorité relative
importante est détenue par sintonia qui
est une société qui est en fin contrôlée
par le groupe Beneton atlana c'est euh
c'est à ce jour euh pas seulement
l'opérateur Prin
principal concessionnaire d'autoroute en
Italie et comme le rappelé monsieur
batiboya aussi au Brésil au Chili et
dans lande en Pologne mais aussi un
opérateur
aéroportuel car elle gère à travers
aéropor de
Rome l'infrastructure aéroportuelle de
Rome c'est un groupe don la valeur de
bourse actuellement c'est supérieur la
capitalisation à à 10 milliardes 11
milliards ou 11 milliardes d'euros
euh je crois que les
délibération des euh des conseil
d'administration il il faudrait les les
demander au directement au
société au aux sociétés actionnaires euh
des des commov
car socitionnaire de Comou pour revenir
à la deè partie de votre question euh je
demande à Monsieur batiboya de vous
donner les éléments de
choix alors euh je crois que on a deux
sujets différents le premier sujet
concernit euh les raisons pour laquell
autostrade participe à des appels
d'offres comme ça euh c'est pas la
première fois
euh des années 90 autostrade est un
petit peu concessionnaire routière un
petit peu spécifique dans le monde parce
qu'il a développé dans les dernières 30
ans euh une connaissance technique
spécifique dans les solutions des péag
et de gestion de trafic euh autostrade
il a l'habitude de développer euh ses
propres solutions pour l'appliquer sur
propre réseau on travaille pas forcément
comme les autres concessionnaires euh
qu'il profitent du marché et qu' se base
exclusivement sur marché et se limite à
faire la maîtrise d'œuvre et la gestion
du projet autostrade a toujours décidé
de développer des solutions propres et
des les mettre mettre cette cette
solution en comparaison avec les marchés
pour être sûr d'acheter toujours les
solutions plus euh propres du point de
vue technique économique aux besoins
spécifiques de l'exploitant euh dans les
cas où c'est autostrade et même
l'exploitant et après on a commencé à se
proposer comme acteur
industriel sur les marchés international
et participer à des des appels d'offres
comme ça l'Autriche que je je viens de
mentionner c'est pas le seul cas où
autostrade a participé on a participé
pratiquement à tous les appels d'offres
de cette nature qui sont déroulé en
Europe dans les dernières 10 ans et en
même temps détiennent une société aux
États-Unis qui est actif dans cette même
domainme pour les marchés nord-américain
qu'utostrade il a vraiment une
connaissance et une savoir-faire
spécifique dans ce domaine qui justifie
nos participations à cette
projet ça c'est pour la première partie
pour la deuxème partie euh c'est pas si
facile à vous répondre quand on rentre
pour chercher de vous convaincre que la
partie
déclarative sera pas plus la la chose
qu' qu'on peut dire ma première chose
autostrade a répondu à on appelle
d'offre et c'est l'état même qui a
spécifié dans ses exigences les
caractéristiques du dispositif à mettre
en place nous on s'est limité à répondre
à des exigences qui déjà de l'offre
initiale était très très prescriptif
nous demandit exactement un système de
cette façon euh il faut aussi rappeler
que aujourd'hui il y a à niveau
européenne euh à la fois une directive
pour l'interopérabilité du entre les
systèmes de télépéage et une autre
directive euh pour l'eurovignette euh
qui euh pose des contraints importants
sous la manière que les différents états
et les concessionnaires pour les compes
de l'État euh collecte une péage une
taxe pour l'utilisation d'un réseau
infrastructure routière euh c'est dans
cet cadre euh juridique législative à
niveau européen qui s'encadre cette
système
euh pendant les 10 15 années de mes
expérience dans dans cette marché
plusieurs fois plusieurs pays sont posé
la question même de d'introduire une
taxe sur sur l'essence sur le Gasol et
de faire bien évidemment c'est c'est
faisable il est beaucoup moins flexible
parce que avec un système électronique
de cette façon il est possible d'adapter
les niveaux tarifaires en fonction des
différents paramètres par exemple
catégorie de véhicule et
potentiellement sur la base du niveau de
congestion des trafic qui s'applique à
les
différents sections
routières vous naviez jamais travaillé
avec l'État français autostrade
préalablement avant ce contrat jamais
hein
piginie sur le territoire français pas
de filiale pas de filiale pas d'é non
je les questions
sur peut-êtreon maintenant
le chapitre de de votre localisation des
locaux de l'immobilier alors vous avez
vous avez posé une question tout à
l'heure sur la nature
de sur la nature de du contrat de
partenariat en réalité nous avons eu
deux signature avec l'État français
premièrement un contrat de partenariat
avec le ministère des Transports qui
portait sur la
fourniture du dispositif donc vous avez
fait allusion tout à l'heure dans votre
question à l'application pour des biens
immobiliers de de
PPP là ce PPP s'appliquait à la
fourniture d'un système c'est-à-dire aux
éléments très concret
qui constitutive du système à savoir
euh
les équipements pour le contrôle les
logiciels enfin toute tout le Hard
relatif à système et ensuite nous avons
signé un contrat de commissionnement
avec les avec les douanes qui nous a
donc délégué un certain nombre de
tâchees sur lequel je me propose de
revenir
euh le
système dans son dans sa dimension
contrôle détecte des anomalies
ces anomalies sont enregistrées dans
notre centre de traitement qui est situé
à met et c'est ce centre qui va traiter
ces anomalies et constituer un
dossier qui sera transmis aux
douanes et c'est l'administration des
douanes qui gardera les tâches
régaliennes c'est-à-dire la
qualification de la fraction
la détermination de l'amende et
procédera à son
recouvrement nous avons un deuxème
rôle en cas de contestation par un
redevable euh de l'infraction à ce
moment-là le dossier revient chez nous
et c'est nous qui élaborons la réponse
au redevable et qui la transmettons aux
douanes voilà pour cette partie
en ce qui concerne donc l'installation à
mes nous avons
effectivement implanté notre centre
d'exploitation à ville de mes après
avoir d'ailleurs consulté d'autres
centres que ce soit à reins à Cala enfin
il y avait d'autres d'autres centres qui
étaient candidat à nous
accueillir nous avons signé avec un bail
donc nous sommes
locataires nous avons signé un bail
commercial avec ma
mopole donc sommes là
simplement locataire d'un bâtiment qui
appartient à une collectivité locale
dans le cadre du plan de reconversion
des
installations de la base aérienne je ne
me souviens plus du numéro
d'ailleurs 128
voilà
en fait nous sommes dans la base aienne
donc notres sont ded dans la base et
nous sommes en fait les première
société qui a pris l'engagement avec M
métropole de installer l'équipe des de
notre société dans la
basarienne avec cette cette logique des
trouver un solution intéressant pour
mropo et pour
nous est-ce qu'on peut avoir à la fois
la durée du bail et et le montant si
c'est pas couvert par le secret
commercial sinon je vous le redemander
un autre moment euh
oui bah ce sont des documents oui que
j'ai pas le la réponse immédiia mais
c'est discutablement des documents qui
sont
publicqus en fait en fait la durée des
de les bail c'est la durée même de les
contrat les partenariats donc nous avons
lié les bails commerciales avec AC les
du de contrat de partenarat à côté en
fait nous avons
faitinestissement nous-même pour faire
tout les renouvement des les locaux du
bâtiment dans les bâtiments de M
donc l'état et la défense permis de dire
fait investissement pour un location
commerciale en qui é concordé avec
l'État
je redonne la parole à Madame la
rapporteur on va peut-être laisser
quelqu
collèges allez monsieur éc Doliger oui
merci madame la Présidente juste
quelques questions après avoir écouté
ces réponses fort intéressantes vous
avez parlé des spécifications techniques
très très
spécifique au niveau européen et au
niveau national donc je voudrais savoir
si les spécifications techniques
françaises où l'on a une habitude très
norm sont supérieures à la moyenne des
normes au niveau européen ce qui
pourrait expliquer des différences de
coût tout à l'heure j'ai entendu avec
intérêt l'intervention de Monsieur
Cornil qui nous a dit que finalement en
Allemagne c'était beaucoup plus cher si
j'ai bien compris qu'en France donc
c'est quand même quelque chose qui
serait intéressant à préciser puisque
effectivement j'allais dire dans la
médiatisation bien souvent c'était
l'inverse qui était exprimé c'est que en
France ça coûtait deux fois plus cher à
l'État français à l'État allemand
puisque si je me souviens bien le coût
global est d'un milillard 200 millions
dont 200 millions annuellement je crois
pour la société ecomove une partie pour
l'État qui doit être 900 millions puis
une partie de 100 et quelques millions
pour les collectivités donc c'est à peu
près les proportions je voudrais savoir
en comparatif par rapport aux autres
pays est-ce que sur le plan technique
les portiques ont un intérêt est-ce que
c'est une spécificité
française ce qui serait intéressant à
savoir puisque s'ils ont pas d'autre
intérêt que de contrôler les
contrevenants mais que ça n'a pas de
rôle dans la facturation est-ce qu'on
peut pas s'en
passer et à ce moment-là est-ce que le
système peut redémarrer sans portique
enfin ou sans rapidement sans remettre
en état tous les portiqu puisque
l'objectif du système c'est quand même
de percevoir une taxe aussi bien pour
l'État que pour l'entreprise que pour
les
collectivités j'aimerais aussi mais
peut-être qu'on pourra pas rentrer dans
le détail mais qu'à l'occasion vous
Facier une analyse sur les délais la loi
disait et vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure dans le Grenel que ça devait
être mis en place en 2011 bon en 2014
pour diverses raisons ça n'est pas mis
en place donc bien évidemment il y a des
manques à gagner donc il serait
intéressant
d'analyser entre la période où cela
aurait dû être contractuellement être
mis en place et aujourd'hui quels sont
tous les manques à gagner et quels sont
les manques à gagner pour chacun des
partenaires que ce soit l'État les
collectivités euh et et bien sûr
l'entreprise et quelles sont les les
incidences voilà globalement les les
questions et effectivement si vous
pouvez nous dire si le cahier des
charges a été un un cahier des charges
extrêmement par rapport à ce que vous
avez connu par ailleurs extrêmement
contraignant j'ai cru comprendre que le
coût global était lié au fait que les
contraintes étaient fortes c'està-dire
que on voulait aller aux défaut si j'ose
dire est-ce qu'il est nécessaire d'avoir
une contrainte aussi forte pour le type
de perception qui est de cette nature
est-ce qu'on aurait pas pu se contenter
pour des contrôles de faire j'allais
dire des des contrôles moins pointus euh
mais des contrôles sur pièces on
contrôlait les véhicules de savoir s'ils
étaient équipés s'ils étaient pas
équipés deuxème
contravention on confisque le véhicule
et ça évite de mettre des portiques donc
ça fait des économies quand même
considérables en matière de gestion
matière technique alors peut-être que je
suis tout à fait à côté de la plaque
mais ça m'intéresserait quand même de
savoir les raisons pour lesquelles il y
a autant de différence ou au moins
différence dans l'expression médiatique
en ce ce qui se fait ailleurs et ce qui
se fait chez nous merci Éric je vais
faire une petite série de questions
peut-être monsieur le Président la des
lois Jean-Pierre sieur veut
s'exprimer parole madame laés croyais
pardonnez-moi je croyaisavais senti
monur je ne vais pas vous décevoir
j'auris de questions à poser
simplement la première question porte
sur le dispositif partenariat public
privé conjoint avec le dialogue
compétitif c'est toujours quelque chose
qui m'a beaucoup
interrogé donc il y avait plusieurs
candidats pour obtenir ce ce
marché il y avait un cahier des charges
initial
ce qui caractérise le dialogue
compétitif c'est que chaque candidat
peut demander ou proposer des
modification au cahier des charges
initiales est-ce que vous pourrez faire
état des modifications que vous avez
successivement
proposé est-ce que ces
modifications ont
été présenter de manière totalement
objective aux autres candidats vous ne
pourrez peut-être pas me répondre mais
par contre avez-vous eu connaissance
dans les mêmes conditions des
modifications proposé par les autres
candidats pouvez-vous établir le
calendrier des modifications qui ont été
demandé par les uns et les autres qui
ont donné lieu à des séquences de
réponse
successiv jusque au choix final parce
que il y a quelque chose de paradoxal
dans le fait que le
candidat devient d'une certaine façon
celui qui contribue à la règle du jeu
par le dialogue compétitif est-ce que
tout cela a été selon vous fait de
manière
irréprochable de manière totalement
claire limpide et qu'on peut venir
fournir l'ensemble des éléments entre le
cahier des charges initiales et le choix
final c'est la première question et la
deuxième question est très simple
beaucoup de Français se disent mais
pourquoi est-ce que cela coûte aussi
cher franchement nous nous sommes tous
dit mais c'est incroyable le prix que
coûte la perception de cette
taxe quelles sont vos réflexions
là-dessus est-ce que comment vous
sentez-vous par rapport au
prix qui apparaît surtout égard au
contexte que vous
connaissez par rapport à la
prestation est-ce que vous ne pensiez
pas que cela aurait pu coûter moins cher
en vérité
profondément alors je fais une dernière
c'est une dernière question pour cette
première série c'est Louis ngre qui
vraiment a demandé la parole merci
madame la
Présidente j'ai deux types de questions
première ce sont des questions
techniques et ensuite je reviendrai
deuxième type de question sur questions
financière la première question vous
avez dit tout à l'heure en présentant
votre dossier que c'était un système
spécifique et innovant alors première
question toute simple c'est innovant en
quoi d'autant plus que tout à l'heure
vous avez dit que vous avez à peu près
le même système mis en place en Autriche
et en Autriche si j'ai bien compris
c'est 2002 donc ça fait plus de 10 ans
et vous êtes toujours les plus innovants
semble-t-il au bout de 10 ans moi je
croyais que le monde évoluait beaucoup
mais là vous êtes en train de nous
apprendre quelque chose alors quelle
différence avec les autres système avec
le système
autrichien vous avez également parlé
d'un pays dont on parle tous et on
compare souvent avec l'Allemagne et le
rapport de l'écotaxe allemande vous nous
avez dit pour faire la différence que ce
système-là était moins efficace qu'il
était plus coûteux pour le contribuable
ou l'usager quelles sont effectivement
les différences entre ce système je je
DIRIS référence en Europe dans dans les
ocotaxes et qu'est-ce qu'il y a là
encore de
différent vous avez également dit tout à
l'heure que vous étiez une société qui
intervient non seulement en Europe mais
dans le monde entier vous avez dit que
vous étiez particulièrement bon j'ai
bien compris ça et donc ma question est
la suivante il y a de très nombreux
appels d'offres qui sont lancés dans le
monde sur ce type là enfin quand je dis
très nombreux il y en a quelquesuns
quand même quel est le pourcentage que
vous avez gagné de marcher dans ce
domaine pour savoir si effectivement
vous êtes cohérent avec ce que vous
annoncez c'était la première série de
questions et je reprendrai celle du
président Jean-Pierre Sueur
effectivement nos concitoyens se posent
la question du coût réel de ce service
de l'intérêt ou pas du portique au prix
où il vaut ça pose problème quand même
et tout à l'heure le président Cornil
disait mais nous on a un système qui
fait que par l' isation satellitaire on
n pas besoin sur le terrain d'avoir quoi
que ce soit alors c'est là où j'ai
quelques difficultés à comprendre
pourquoi vous doublez finalement le
système par quelque chose de
particulièrement onéreux au point que
certains esprits
taacin se sont demandé si d'aventure les
portiques ne pourrait pas servir à
d'autres but que le simple contrôle des
poisss lourds qui passent et voir à
terme je pose des questions je suis là
pour donc je pose des questions c'était
la première série de questions sur la
technique sur les
finances quelle est la réénumération de
votre prestation
annuellement pour parce que le président
suur l'a dit tout à l'heure un milliard
2 à peu près mais je suis administrateur
à la fit et je m'aperçois
que votre prestation si j'en crois les
chiffres qui m'ont été communiqués est
une prestation que l'on qualifiera
d'levé surtout euh pour prélever une
taxe et là vous avez un montant de
prélève enfin de prestations pour
prélever la taxe qui nous paraît très
très important et donc la fite pour les
infrastructures de transport a moins
d'argent ce qui est un problème
ensuite une question également quel
serait le prix du rachat
d'comov par l'État si d'aventure l'état
décidait de racheter éc mou et si
c'était le cas si c'était le cas quel
montant de dédommagement
demanderiez-vous à
l'état on va s'arrêter là est très
fourni madame le rapporteur pardon oui
c'est c'est juste pour compléter la la
dernière question de notre collègue
Louis Nère sur les rachats et les
sessions que pensez-vous aussi de la
clause qui existe me semble-t-il
permettant au contraire à ecomov de
revendre à une autre société l'anemb
emble du dispositif au bout de 2 ans
sans que l'État français n'it rien à y
redire allez qui veut commencer à la
réponse c'est Monsieur Cournil monsieur
batiboya d'abord d'abord les aspects
techniques et donc monsieur batiboya va
répondre sur tout ce qui concerne le
système les portiques et l'intérêt de de
ce dispositif par rapport au au
dispositifs autrichien et allemand sur
un plan
technique alors euh tout d'abord je je
commence à faire un peu des comparaisons
entre les systèmes français et les
autres systèmes européenses euh
car si on va au-delà des frontières
européennes on ne trouve pas forcément
des exemples euh pertinent parce que
au-delà de l'Europe il y a simplement
notamment aux États-Unis et en Asie des
système très localisé à niveau local euh
avec des des distances et des niveaux de
trafic complètement différents euh c'est
l'Europe les marchés plus avancés dans
les systèm de collecte d'une péage ou
d'une taxe à niveau national en flux
libre ça veut dire sans euh des
infrastructures lourdes euh et des
impacts sur les trafics qui qui roulent
sur les réseaux routiers
concernés il y a principalement en
Europe euh des grandes familles de
systèmes tout d'abord il y a seulement
4ou C pays qui se sont qui ont installé
des systèmes de cette nature euh
l'Autriche je suis très heureux parce
que moi j'étais j'ai fait partie du
projet était le premier système à niveau
national euh car l'Allemagne a démarré
les projets bien avant mais il a où
beaucoup de problèmes à mettre en
service le système l'Autriche est rentré
en service les 1er janvier 2004 euh
l'Allemagne au moins en parti du système
allemand euh c'est par c'est passé 2005
après on a la République tchèque on a eu
la Slovaquie récemment la Pologne ça son
les cinq pays qu'il font des références
au niveau européen à côté il faut
mentionner parce qu'il est correct parce
que géographiquement il s'agit d'un pays
Européenne la Suisse aussi il a un
système des naturees similaires syntaxe
c'est appliqué à tous les véhicules la
Suisse par rapport aux autres autes pays
il a en spécificité très important la
Suisse a mis en place un système selon
lequel tous les poids lourds euh il
payent une taxe sur la totalité du
réseau routière Suisse et pas seulement
sur un réseau primaire comme ça peut
être la le réseau conid ou le
réseau départemental ou national ça veut
dire qu'un Suisse en poilure Suisse au
étranger il paye même pour rouler autour
de sa ville à l'intérieur de son son
boîte c'est sur la base du kilomètre
percourou sur base mensuelle qui en
Suisse la taxe est appliqué c'est un peu
une exception et même la Suisse est en
train de réfléchir sur l'évolution de ce
système qui ça date 2002 euh après les
autres systèmes il s ragrouper sur des
solutions principales il y a une
solution
satellitaire comme l'Allemagne la
Slovaquie et on espère la France et des
des solutions DSRC ça veut dire basé sur
une oou la détection des franchissements
par chaque véhicule d'un point de
tarification c'est fait à travers en
communication entre une équipe embarqué
et un équipe
l'Autriche la République tchèque et la
Pologne sont des systèmes qui ont adopté
cette
deuxè typologie de des systèmes et la
réseau routière concerné par les
paiements de cette péage est couverte
par plusieurs dizaines plusieurs
centaines des portiques qui servent à la
même au même temp pour la collecte de la
taxe et sur base statistique typiquement
entre 5 et 10 % des portiques ils sont
utilisés aussi pour le contrôle ça c'est
la grande la grande famille des systèmes
et typiquement des systèmes comme ça ils
sont très bien adaptés euh soit quand il
y a beaucoup de véhicules qui sont
concerné parce que les coût de
l'équipement embarqué dans ces cas-là
est très faible autour de 10 15 € euh ou
quand la la réseau routière est très
limité parce que le nombre des porti en
ce cas-là c'est autant limité et les
coût d'investissement c'est pas si
important et facilement
euh morté pendant la phase
d'exploitation euh là où le nombre de
véhicules
euh pas pas si énorme et la mais la
réseau de routière devient de plus en
plus important euh la solution
satellitaire devient euh beaucoup plus
intéressant du point de vue économique
euh pour pour l'État pour pour lui qui
qui encasse cette cette pH et taxe et
c'est là que l'Allemagne été le premier
à mettre en place cette système
euh la Slovaquie a suivi euh
2009 et maintenant la France est le 3ème
pays euh qui c'est parti sur une
solution de ce typeel je tiens à euh à
souligner que l'État français dans la CR
charge il n'a pas spécifié une solution
technologique précise euh chaque
candidat les caill des charges était
techniquement neutre de la même façon
que ça a été fait dans les autres pays
européennes c'est la Commission
européenne qui est très vigilant dans
cette point de vue et les spécifications
techniques et fonctionnelles étaient t
que un candidat pouvait bien proposer
une solution basé sur des portiques de
la même façon qu'un autreiche République
tchèque euh autostrade et après ecomove
a décidé euh qui est la l'extension de
la réseau routière français et surtout
la topologie de cette réseau euh où les
qui est qui est caractérisé par plus de
4000 points de tarification
ça veut dire que 4000 portiques
normalement euh vont être nécessair de
mettre en place c'était pas
économiquement viable et une solution de
telle nature n'était pas du tout
flexible parce qu'elle ne permet pas euh
des modifier de manière flexible
d'étendre les réseaux taxable ou de
réduire réseau taxable en fonction de la
décision politique des niveau de trafic
qui on peut enregistrer sur réseau c'est
pour cette raison qu'on a décidé de
proposer solution satellitaire
euh à l'état des l'art actuel
euh l'Allemagne c'est vrai qui les
systèmes référence dans cette dans cette
dans cette marché parce que a été les
premiier systèm à utiliser la
technologie satellitaire pour faire du
péage et de la collecte il faut pas
oublier que il s'agit de plus de 10 ans
il y a il y a 10 ans que l'appel d'offre
allemand a été lancé et la technologie
est changé de manière très importante
euh pour vous donner
une quelque chose que nous tous on
utilise tous les jours le système
allemand est toujours basé sur en
communication entre l'équipe embarqué et
les systèmes central sur des SMS parce
qu'il y avait pas les GPRS les
communications 3G au débit qu' on a
aujourd'hui ça veut dire que la solution
technique allemand est daté de 2002 euh
aujourd'hui nous on peut proposer des
solutions euh qui en s'appuyant sur des
technologies bien avancées des
télécommunications et même sur des
solutions plus précises à niveau
localisation satellitaire il n'y
aomu va proposer une solution
satellitaire qui utilise au même temps
les GPS américaines euh les glonas euh
Rouses euh et des techniquement prêt à
utiliser aussi les signaux du système
galileéo ça veut dire que ça ça ça
montre déjà la différence entre les
systèmes allemands que ça peut être vu
comme un système vieux et que
l'Allemagne est en train
de remplacer un appel d'offre
potentiellement sera lancé en 2015 pour
remplacer le système aujourd'hui les
technologies nous permet de proposer un
système beaucoup plus performant qui
nous donne beaucoup plus de flexibilité
et nous la possibilité d'être d'être
plus
performant l'Allemagne en terme de
kilomètres il est vrai qui la la réseau
texable pourut être comparable parce
qu'il s'agit de 12000 km mais en
Allemagne on parle des autoroutes on ne
parle pas des routes départementales la
la topographie la topologie du réseau
est bien plus différent
ici et nous a par
exemple amené à avoir des des des
problèmes des des particuliers pour
assurer que la détection des des
passages de points de terrification et
surtout euh
la la fausse détection les détection
positive euh soit limité en sous du
niveau demandé par la démarche deogation
l'important avec des routes euh très
proches l'une de l'autre et d'éviter de
taxer un véhicule qu'il passe sur la
route à côté de la périphérique de Paris
euh quand il est pas il doit pas payer
une taxe en Allemagne il y a pas trop
cette problématique ici en France la
topographie de la du réseau est très
important et nécessite des équipements
embarqués très précises
euh la la démarche d'homologation
l'arrêté d'homologation sur laquelle
basse les
systèmes à la fois des comov et les
dispositifs que chacune des achetés a
décidé de mettre en place sont été
homologués prescrivent que les taux de
taxation à torte
doit être inférieur à une sur un million
de
cas et pour atteindre C niveau de
performance il faut un équipement
satellitaire très performant qu' utilise
qu' profite au mux de la
technologie à la fois au niveau
mais aussi en terme des algorithmes des
traitement des données qui permet des
assurer d'atteindre les niveau des
performances
demandé les porti pour contrôle euh je
suis d'accord potentiellement
euh ces systèmesl ont n'ont pas besoin
de portique parce que les les portiques
ils ne sont pas du tout utilisés euh
pour collecter la taxe euh ça c'est un
niveau pour potentiel euh bien
évidemment et ça c'est un choix qui a
été fait par tous les systèmes en Europe
et dans le monde il y a aucun système
qui n'a qui n'a pas des des des
portiques il y a toujours un certain
nombre de portiques toujours euh des
manières pour faire des contrôles
statistiques et sur des points à très
haut trafic euh parce que l'utilisation
d'un portique de cette nature même si
l'investissement initial peut être
important il est beaucoup plus efficace
en terme d'exploitation parce que c'est
vrai on pourra dire on peut faire
seulement des contrôle manuel demander à
la police de faire des contrôles sur
route oui mais il faut une un volume des
agents de contrôle très très important
pour arriver à faire des vérifications
capillaires sur 800000 véhicules
potentiels qui roulent en France et de
la même façon pour les autres
pays donc le por si vous permettez le
portic sert non pas à localiser le PO
lourd mais contrôler que tous les poids
lourds sont bien destenteurs d'un
appareil qui permet de les localiser
donc c'est pour lutter contre la fraude
c'est bien ça ça oui sauf qu'il y a
quand même dit-on quelques portiques qui
sont installés sur le réseau sont
positionnés sur les axes du réseau non
taxables on m'a cité des exemples dans
ma belle Aquitaine en pyrénée Atlantique
par exemple donc je voudrais comprendre
justement pourquoi alors moi moi j'ai
j'ai je préfère que cette deuxème
question c'est plutôt l'État qui qui
doit répondre parce que c'est l'État qui
nous a demandé de mettre en place cette
point il faut il faut se
rappeler non non non c'est pas seulement
ça
il faut se rappeler que les
prescriptions de l'État l'état il
prescrive que euh au plus tard à la date
de mise en vigueur de la taxe tous les
poils lourds assjettis français et ils
doiv être équipé tout le temps avec un
équipe embarqué même quand il roule au
dehors des réseau taxables même si cette
équipe embarqué au dehors des Rabl ne
collecte pas des positionnements pas du
tout et n'enregistre pas de la de la
taxe
euh ça ça peut expliquer d'une certaine
manière l'utilisation des C point audà
des des des réseaux taxables il s'agit
des six points ils sont 6 points sur
173 portique en proportion quel est le
coût d'investissement sur les portiques
et quel est le coût d'investissement sur
le reste du dispositif c'est les
dispositif embarqué à peu près la la
répartition pour
ecomove
170 quce qui répond monsieur corn on va
on aborde ça
oui vous souhaitez queou on souhait que
ce soit abordé dans il est certain que
sur toutes les questions financières on
a dit qu'on ferait une audition
spécifique d'abord qui se justifie
totalement puisque on va demander à la
Cour des comptes de de travailler sur
ces questions financières liées au
contrat donc il faut laisser un peu le
temps aussi à la Cour des comptes de de
regarder tout ça et je pense en plus
qu'il faudra probablement sur ces
questions financières faire une une
audition conjointe avec le ministère
aussi donc ça c'est vrai que si vous le
souhaitez c'est une question qu'on
peut voilà Joker madame le rapporteur
mais c'est bien quand même qu'on l' posé
pour que vous ayez sachez qu'on va y
revenir très vite je voudrais la réponse
quand même même si c'est pas aujourd'hui
non mais vous vous l'aurez c'est j'ai
j'ai tout dernierre point concernant
l'évolution du C des chargees
euh honnêtement l'expérience que on a
fait dans cet appel d'offre est que
euh les échanges entre l'État et chacune
des candidats on peut parler pour
l'expérience qu'on a fait on n' pas des
éléments des échanges entre l'État et
les autres candidats on n'a pas accès à
cette information
on ne connaît pas non plus de nature de
manière formelle quel type de solution
les autres avaient
proposer ce qui est important mentionner
est
que interrompre la loi prévoit que si un
candidat préconise une
modification les autres candidats
doivent en temps réel en être informé et
que vous avez dû être informé en temps
réel
non mais vous faites comme ça est-ce que
vous avez été informé en temps réel ou
n'avez pas été informé des modifications
proposées par les autres candidats c'est
extrêmement important parce que
l'égalité face au marché public fait que
si le cahier des charges change suite à
la proposition d'un candidat les autres
candidat doivent strictement en être
informés donc la réponse préc à cette
question est extrêmement
importante l'impression l'expérience est
que le CAH des charge n'a pas évolué
suite à la demande des
candidats les CAH des charg Inial et
final n'a pas vraiment changé des
manières important et surtout sur la
baseandat suis extrêmement précis est-ce
qu'il a changé pas changé c'est-à-dire
est-ce que vous affirmez que le cahier
des charges est strictement le même
entre le début et la fin du compétitif
où est-ce qu'il a changé je veux savoir
s'il a changé ou s'il n'a pas changé il
a changé bon donc il a changé parce que
j'ai dit qu'il n'a pas sensiblement
changé puis qu'il a changé est-ce que
vous pouvez nous produire peut-être pas
immédiatement l'ensemble des points où
il y a eu changement avec le calendrier
et les pièces qui atteste que vous avez
été évidemment mis au courant des
modifications proposées par les autres
candidats et nous pourrons demander aux
autres candidats s'ils ont eu
communication des modifications que vous
avez proposé parce que c'est pas quelque
chose où l'État est en dialogue
singulier avec chaque candidat et non il
faut à tous les moments j'insiste sinon
ça peut mettre en cause l'égalité bien
entendu vous le savez du processus qu'à
tous les moments il y ait égalité devant
la commande publique tout à fait tout à
fait on va faire appel au témoignage
d'Antoine Capu qui était là également au
moment de réponse à appel
d'offre pour être tout à fait précis on
parle de
comparer le cahé des charges qui a servi
à l'établissement des offres initiales
qui ont été déposé le 7 janvier
2010 et ce qu'on appelle le ddof c'est
le dossier définitif des offres finales
qui a été publié par l'État avec
évidemment une stricte égalité devant
tous les
candidats le 12 juillet 2010
entre les deux il y a la période de
dialogue qui a constitué en à notre
connaissance neu réunions en tout cas
nous nous avons fait neu
réunions et qui a évidemment évidemment
donner lieu à un certain nombre
d'évolution
ou
d'ajustement du cahier des charges mais
pas simplement du Cayet des charges des
quantitatifs
d'équipement des
euh prescription réglementaire puisque
de
mémoire lors du cahier des charges
initiale lors de la consultation
initiale nous n'avions pas le guide de
procédure par exemple qui est la
traduction dans des termes je dirais
métiers de la douane des prescriptions
fonctionnelles du
dispositif donc qui sont les
prescriptions plus je dirais technique
opérationnell du dispositif nous
n'avions
pas il y a il y a eu également de
mémoire des évolutions sur les projets
d'arrêt arrêé d'homologation comme l'a
rappelé monsieur batiboya c'est un
élément
important et distinctif du projet
français c'est que le dispositif
français l'État a voulu l'homologuer
pour lui donner force de
preuve il y a eu des
évolutions vous citiez le coût du
système de
contrôle qui est il est vrai important
mais justement l'État en a pris
conscience puisque de mémoire il y a une
réduction sensible du nombre de contrôle
automatique fixe entre le C des charges
initial et le cahier des charges final
ce sont des évolutions qui sont
évidemment inhérentes et tout à fait
naturelles au cadre d'un dialogue
compétitif
mais je n'ai
pas souvenir que dans les échanges que
autostrade pouvait conduire avec l'État
euh
il y a eu de véritables suggestions de
fait c'est l'État qui en analysant les
proposition initiale reçu le 7 janvier
de la part des différents candidats a
dit voilà ça c'est trop cher je réduis
les quantités là effectivement je prends
conscience qu'il peut y avoir telle ou
telle difficulté et j'y réfléchis et
j'ajuste et ils ont décidé ça par eux et
je ne crois pas du tout que l'égalité
entre les candidats que vous que vous
soullignez à évidemment de façon
extrêmement pertinente n'a été en quoi
que ce
soit touché
d'ailleurs comme nous l'avons rappelé le
ça été un des sujets du contentieux le
Conseil d'État regarda ces chosesl avec
beaucoup beaucoup de de de de de de
d'intérêt et beaucoup de de détails
beaucoup d'études et la conclusion a été
que voilà le processus s'était déroulé
d'une façon parfaitement normale mais
nous pourrons lister effectivement
l'ensemble des modifications c'est un
travail un peu fastidieux puisqu'il y a
quandême beaucoup de de points mais
voilà j'ai j'ai j'ai cité un certain
nombre de d'évolutions
caractéristiques cette recherche dans
Archiv je je voudrais maintenant faire
la transition avec les questions qui ont
été posées sur le sur le prix et
peut-être dire quelques mots
sur sur le comparatif avec l'Allemagne
euh je vais vous donner quatre chiffres
euh en France je vous donne des chiffres
très arrondis hein en France nous avons
un
système qui va coûter par an aux
alentours de 200 230 millions c'est les
chiffres vous citiez que je confirme
pour collecter 1 milliard 2 de taxes au
total en Allemagne c'est un système qui
coûte un peu plus de 500 millions 530 je
crois
510 et pour collecter 4 milliards de de
taxe la grosse différence elle a été
soulignée tout à l'heure par Monsieur
batiboya c'est que c'est le réseau
autoroutier qui a donc des densités de
circulation
importantes qui est couvert par le
système et qui donc explique cette
différence entre les chiffres donc un
système plus cher en Allemagne mais qui
collecte plus de taxes par rapport à
nous maintenant je voudrais souligner
que monsieur btiboya l'a bien spécifié
que le système français est évolutif et
qu' pourrait y avoir d'autres
applications qui puissent être envisagé
l'extension juste petite précision donc
500 millions pour 4 milliards c'est en
pourcentage inférieur à 200 millions
pour 1 milliard 2 on raisonnait sur des
pourcentages on parlait
pas c'est donc le système est avec
ceinture et bretelle
si et et mais si en France on l'utiliser
pour collecter les péages on serait en
situation très
différente alors madame le rapporteur
est-ce que le coût en France n'est pas
aussilié à la durée très courte
d'amortissement du Matel parce que c'est
un PPP sur une durée courte quand même
voilà et de de mémoire si je me rappelle
bien les chiffres que j'ai lu mais
ecomove aura très vite entre guillemets
récupéré son investissement ou en tout
cas relativement vite par rapport à ce
qui se fait habituellement là on va
peut-être un peu rentrer dans les
détails tout petit peu les débats on va
quand même prendre la question si vous
voulez bien de monsieur grosidier qui la
réclame depuis longtemps et de Monsieur
Nère qui demande de revenir un tout
petit peu alors Monsieur rodidier oui
merci et Monsieur sur qui je ne peux
rien refuser euh première question y y
a-t-il des des systèmes comparables dans
les modalités en Europe ou dans le monde
qui sont en régie direct de l'État
puisque à cette occasion certaines voies
ont dénoncé le part public privé en
regrettant que l'État n'ait pas mené
cette mise en rég direct est-ce que ça
existe et si oui est-ce que vous en
connaissez les coûts
euh vous avez répondu à déjà la ma
question qui était de savoir si vous
aviez le sentiment par d'avoir été mieux
informé ou mieux écouté mieux entendu ou
mieux favorisé que que que les que la
concurrence je voudrais par contre
savoir si vous aviez eu de la part de
l'actuel gouvernement des observations
ou des demandes d'explication
d'éclaircissement sur à la fois
l'attribution du contrat et des
modalités de mise en œuvre avant que les
polémiques n'apparaissent
postérieurement à l'annonce de la
suspension de de l'échotaxe euh
consécutif aux événements de Bretagne je
voulais savoir aussi par quelle modalité
précise le gouvernement vous avez
prévenu de cette suspension qui vous
affectait directement savoir si vous
l'avez su comme nous par la presse et
savoir si le gouvernement ou
l'administration de l'État c'était avant
cette décision même dans les heures qui
précédaient approcher de vous pour
mesurer les conséquences de ces
décisions les conséquences financières
éventuellement je reviendrai les
conséquences sociales j'aimerais savoir
également à combien vous estimez le
préjudice pour vous pour l'État pour les
collectivités territoriales en cas
dei en fonction du délai de suspension
puisqu'on a plusieurs délais ont été
annoncés et en cas
d'abandon de suspension sinédié ou
d'abandon définitif euh je voudrais
également connaître le coût social
notamment Mosel de cette suspension où
250 emplois étaient attendus
effectivement sur le site de la BA 128
où l'État a forcé la main de mes
métropole pour euh l'amener à prendre ce
site en responsabilité plus rapidement
que prévu à des conditions mal négociées
euh pour justement pouvoir accueillir
eomove euh donc je voudrais savoir ce
qu'il en est aujourd'hui des CDI qui ont
été créés et des CDI qui étaient prévu
on en a combien sur les 250 emplois
prévus que deviennent aujourd'hui les
CDI sont-ils touchés par des mesures de
chômage partiel qu'en est-il des des CDD
je suis informé qu' de CDD n'aurait pas
été renouvelé en en décembre d'ailleurs
pour beaucoup de demandeurs d'emploi qui
arrivaient en fin de droit parce qu'il
vivait dans la perspective de cet emploi
certains se retrouvent aujourd'hui au
RSA ou à la SS donc je voudrais savoir
quels sont les dispositifs
d'accompagnements sociaux que vous pu
mettre en œuvre comme on le fait en
général lorsque se met en uvre un plan
social en relation entre les service de
l'État et et et l'employeur et enfin à
combien ce sont élevés
les coûts de formation assuré financés
par vous par pô emploi ou par d'autres
financeurs et pour quelle perspective
aujourd'hui question et je vais quand
même en rajouter une est-ce que la mise
à disposition a été faite aujourd'hui ou
pas parce que dans un contrat de PPP
c'est un des points clés très important
c'est la mise à disposition donc ce que
je souhaite savoir si elle a été faite
officiellement aujourd'hui et quand
est-ce que vous comptez le faire quand
vous dites on est prêt on est prêt mais
à un moment donné il faut que ça se
concrétise par rapport à la mise à
disposition alors Monsieur Nigre mais
pour très vite parce qu'il a beaucoup
parlé madame la Présidente je ne fais
que renouveler la question de tout à
l'heure qui est quel est le montant de
la rémunération donc c'est 230 millions
pour une recette d'un milliard 2 ça fait
à peu près 20 % en Allemagne c'est 510
millions pour 4 milliards donc c'est du
12 % donc une des choses qui ont
interpellé c'est pour percevoir tel
montant je vais devoir débours c'est un
montant plus élevé en France
proportionnellement qu'en Allemagne donc
la question était je la renouvelle
est-ce que le montant de la prestation
n'est pas excessif et j'avais deux
autres questions dédommagement ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure quel
dédommagement allez-vous demander à
l'État s'il n'y a pas l'application du
système je je le rappelle et le prix
d'achat dcou parler très bien
Jean-Pierre et à Monsieur Capu si j'ai
bien compris sa réponse signifie
qu'entre le cahier des charges initial
et celui de la fin il n'y a eu aucune
aucun changement dû à une proposition
d'un des candidats mais que tous les
changements ont été décidés par l'État
suite au vu des conversations qu'il a eu
avec les différents
candidats est-ce que j'ai bien compris
je dirais que les les candid compléterur
pour compléter la question de madame la
Présidente sur est-ce que l'on est prêt
est-ce que le l'ensemble du dispositif
est livré ou pas vous nous avez parlé de
25000 facturation détaillée
pardonnez-moi si j'emplois pas le terme
précis mais c'est 25000 sur quel nombre
de factures attendu c'estàd que le test
repose sur quel pourcentage euh de ce
que vous en attendez quand on sera à T
plein ou à mois mois plein ou année
pleine peu importe on on saura faire le
le le distingo nous-même et les les
10000 poids lourd et les 10 millions
d'éléments de tarification que vous avez
produit sont-ils contradictoires
autrement dit ont-ils pu être vérifiés
testés par les entreprises qui les
auraiit reçu si on était réellement en
tarification et dernière question le
dispositif est une chose mais on a parlé
tout à l'heure de l'agrément des agents
chargés du recouvrement euh quid de cet
agrément une fois de plus est-ce que ce
sera vraiment le préfet les douanes
comment ça va se passer est-ce qu'on est
prêt aussi sur ce sujet-là j'entends
bien que vous avez envie d'être prêt
officiellement prêt puisque on l'é ne
vous devra déloyer qu'à partir du moment
où tout sera livré mais voilà est-on
réellement prêt êtes-vous réellement
prêt alors toutes ces questions sont
très importantes et madame le rapporteur
a eu beaucoup de raison de parler aussi
de la marche à blanc parce que
franchement je crois que vous avez
travaillé surtout avec les grosses
entreprises quand même pas beaucoup avec
les petites et les moyennes cette March
à blanc hein ça aussi il faudra nous le
dire allez qui répond monsieur Cournil
moi ce que je vous propose c'est qu'on
aborde peut-être le sujet des prix qui
qui est assez récurrent qui revient
plusieurs fois donc on va vous expliquer
monsieur Capu va vous expliquer
effectivement la constitution de notre
prix et puis après moi j'ai noté que je
propose de répondre aux questions de
Monsieur grosidier sur tout ce qui
concerne mes le centre de mes les
emplois et cetera je vous propose P sur
en cet
oui avant de venir sur le sujet de la
rémunération je voudrais répondre à la
question de Monsieur
sur je dirais que
l'objet du dialogue compétitif en tout
cas c'est comme ça que autostrade l'a
géré pour ce qu' le concerne était
d'expliquer l'offre initiale
remise il était de répondre aux
questions de l'État pourquoi avez-vous
proposé telle solution pourquoi
avez-vous fait tel choix comment
expliquez-vous tel
équipement comment arrivez-vous à ce
prix à ces éléments de votre
offre ça n'est pas exactement ce qu'on
peut appeler des propositions si ce
n'est que évidemment la base de cette
réflexion était l'offre initiale remise
le 7 janvier c'est sur la base de ce
dialogue que l'État a pris ses décisions
d'évolution pour
lesquel autostrade n'a rien fait d'autre
que d'expliquer euh
les choix et le pourquoi du
comment des propositions faites dans
l'offre initiale c'est bien le fondement
de l'initiation d'un dialogue compétitif
autrement si on n' pas un document
d'entrée on n pas de fondement à
discussion voilà ce que je dirais sur ce
point
euh alors pour ce qui concerne la
rémunération des comov d'abord pour
repréciser quelles sont les bases de son
établissement bon cette rémunération
elle est fixée par le contrat sur une
base
trimestrielle et elle est dû par l'État
à compter madame la Présidente l'a
rappelé madame la rapporteur également
de la mise à disposition du
dispositif et elle est d sur une base
trimestrielle à date fixe dans le
contrat la rémunération doit être versée
au 1er mars au 1er juin au 1er septembre
et au 1er décembre je veux dire par là
que ce ne sont pas des trimestres
glissant en fonction du moment où est
constaté la mise à
disposition je vous précise tout de
suite un point très important et qui a
été récurrent dans le débat médiatique
c'est que cette rémunérra
n'est aucunement un pourcentage du
montant de la taxe collectée on se livre
à des comparaison avec le système
allemand dont on pourrait d'ailleurs
dire
que en fait le système allemand a coûté
bien plus cher qu'il ne coûte
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on parle de 510
millions qui est la rémunération du
consortium qui exploite le système
allemand sur la base 2012 mais ce
système a coûté beaucoup plus cher à son
origine parce que comme tout système il
fait l'objet de certaines amélioration
et puis il y a eu également des
négociations entre l'État allemand et le
consortium to collect pour revoir un
montant qui était manifestement aux yeux
de l'État allemand trop
élevé
alors dans tout ce débat qu'il y a eu
sur la runération des comov on a vu
différents chiffres
circuler dans le
contrat les valeurs de rémunération sont
exprimé sur une base extrêmement précise
ce sont des valeurs qui sont exprimées
bien entendu comme l'habitude dans ces
contrats là hors
taxe et qui sont
basé sur janvier
2011 en effet dans ce contrat on a un
contrat qui est sur une durée
d'exploitation de 11 ans et demi et donc
la
rémunération une partie de la
rémunération du prestataire est indexée
elle suit la base d'un certain nombre
d'indice formulle de révision qui sont
dans le contrat et qui sont basés sur
des indices Inc et qui
sont là pour traduire l'inflation qui
seraée tout au long
de la vie du contrat donc les valeurs
que je vais vous indiquer maintenant et
je le
précise le plus clairement possible sont
des valeurs qui sont faites sur cette
base du contrat hors taxe en valeur
janvier
2011 si je veux décomposer donc la
rémunération des
comm je dirais que nous avons d'abord
une première partie qui est une partie
fixe qui elle n'est pas indexée qui est
ferme et non révisable pourquoi parce
que c'est la partie qui rémunère les
investissements et qui rémunère les
moyens de financement qui ont été
utilisés pour construire le
dispositif cette cette première partie
fixe s'élève à 96 millions d'euros par
an
il y a une deuxième partie fixe
également qui rémunère les coûts de
maintenance du dispositif les coûts de
gestion quand je dis fixe c'est parce
que autre
caractéristique de la rémunération une
partie de cette rémunération c'était
l'objet d'une des questions une partie
de la rémunération est dite variable
parce que elle s'ajuste en fonction de
la charge
observer sur le dispositif en
terme de transaction de collecte et en
terme de manquement en ce qui concerne
la fraude de façon à ce que la
rémunération du prestataire soit adaptée
soit ajusté à la hausse comme à la
baisse en fonction du travail réellement
le travail d'exploitation réellement
réalisé donc cette deuxième partie fixe
qui rémunère les coûts de maintenance du
dispositif les coûs de
gestion c'estàdire en particulier les
les les salaires les loyers les frais de
fonctionnement les assurances les frais
généraux de la société
ecomove et qui rémunère également le
résau de
distribution ce montant là il s'élève
sur les mêmes bases encore une fois hors
taxe janvier 2011 pour être sûr d'avoir
une même référence à 47 millions d'euros
auquel s'ajoute je le pré dis 8 million
d'euros qui est un compte budgétaire
spécifique et qui va servir à ce qu'on
appelle le gros entretien renouvellement
c'est-à-dire que une des
caractéristiques et ça a été souligné
également précédemment c'est la relative
courte durée de ce contrat de
partenariat mais une autre
caractéristique et qui est différente
justement du de la solution allemande ou
du cadre contractuel allemand c'est que
au bout de ce contrat de partenariat
l'ensemble du dispositif revient
gratuitement à l'état l'État en prend la
PR la pleine possession et de façon à ce
que le prestataire soit tenu de
restituer à l'état un dispositif qui
soit dans un état correct de
fonctionnement qui ne soit pas arrivé où
tous les composants technique du système
ne soit pas arrivé à leur fin de vie et
bien la rémunération prévoit un budget
spécifique qui est suivi
spécifiquement de façon à ce
que en fin de contrat les différents
équipements qui le nécessit puissent
être remplacés et que l'État récupère un
système qu'il peut exploiter facilement
sans avoir besoin de refaire des
investissements importants de remise en
état du dispositif excusez-moi je vous
coupe à cet instant pour être sûr de
bien comprendre l'ensemble du dispositif
revient à l'état et le personnel les
agents de eomov qui savent le faire
fonctionner qui sont agrémentés d'ici là
on l'espère en tout cas sont aussi mis à
disposition de l'État ou reste personnel
ecomove le contrat prévoit l'obligation
pour ecomov d'assurer la transmission du
savoir et la transmission des personnels
dans des évidemment dans des conditions
qui sont prescrites de façon à ce que
évidemment l'État ne reçoivent pas un
dispositif qu'il serait dans
l'incapacité dans la capacité
d'exploiter donc tout ceci est
parfaitement prescrit par le
contrat donc euh je vous ai dit euh dans
un premier temps
euh une première partie fixe de 96
millions une seconde que je viens de
citer de 55 millions hein 47 + 8 ce qui
donne 151 millions de partie
fixe annuelle hors taxe valeur janvier
2011 il y a une partie
variable qui donc est fonction du
travail réalisé
par travail d'exploitation réalisé par
eCom et par les sociétés habilité au
télépéage qui s'élève à environ 64
million d'euros hors taxe
et cette valeur de 64 millions d'euros
vous l'aurez compris évidemment comme
c'est une valeur variable
est calculé sur des prévisions de trafic
et des prévisions de frude qui ont été
indiqués par l'État dans le contrat et
qui ont été indiqués par l'état non
seulement dans le contrat mais également
dans les documents de consultation de
façon à ce que la comparaision des
différentes offres s'établissent sur des
bases qui soient exactement identiques
pour tous les candidats voilà alors
cette valeur de 64 millions je ne peux
pas évidemment vous l'aurez compris
certifier que ça sera bien la valeur
exacte de la rémunération puisque c'est
une valeur qui par définition dépendra
du trafic réel observé de la charge
réelle observée sur le
système voilà en ce qui concerne la
rémunération des com votre par
et bien elle rémunère l'ensemble des
travaux l'ensemble dans un système qui
repose sur par exemple la communication
de données s'il y a moins de trafic s'il
y a plus de trafic la charge de
communication qui est générée qu'il faut
payer aux opérateurs diffère la charge
de travail
administratif de de d'établissement des
factures de transmission de ces factures
au redev
dont la plupart se fera par les SHT
parce que dans ces 64 millions que j'ai
cité la très grande majorité de ces 64
millions reviennent en en fait au SHT
n'est pas une rémunération c'est une
rémunération qui est perçu par ecomove
mais qui est transféré aux différentes
sociétés commerciales qui on l'a dit
commercialise le le le service écotax
pois lourd auprès de leur flotte de
transporteurs déjà client aujourd'hui
pour un certain nombre d'autres services
comme vous le savez le le Tiss pois
lourd ou d'autres services qui sont
inhérents à la profession de
transporteur routier les coût post je
voilà al évidemment les coûts postaux de
transmission des factures les coûts de
traitement des opérations de fraude
voilà c'est c'est de façons à ajuster le
dispositif à sa charge réelle je vais
donner la parole si vous êtes vous me
permettez à Monsieur cap canellaa qui
l'a demandé en faisant bien observer que
donc vous avez raisoné hors taxe et à
mon avis vous avez raison je dis pour
mes collègues ça veut bien dire que vous
vous allez payer la TVA 20 % sur sur ces
sommeslà que l'État récupère par
ailleurs sur un autre compte monsieur
pas sur au budget général pas sur
le le compte de la fite hein on est
d'accord je donne cette petite précision
qui en terme d'équilibre est quand même
pas
àodine merci madame la Présidente je
voulais justement rebondir sur sur
l'exposé que nous venons d'entendre sur
en particulier la rémunération des
investissements j'ai entendu le chiffre
de 96 millions d'euros de rémunération
des investissements hein à quel
pourcentage cela correspond je crois
qu'il faut le calculer par rapport à 500
millions à peu près d'investement estce
que c'est bien le
cas puon pour nous confirmer donc le
taux de
rémunération et est-ce qu'on n pas dans
ce cas-là en faisant un calcul rapide
quand même sur le haut des fourchettes
observé quand on regarde des PPP compara
euh on arrive quand même à un taux de
rémunération relativement élevé du
capital investi euh en conséquence quels
sont les risques que vous prenez est-ce
que vous poulez détailler et quels sont
les risques qui justifient qui est ce
niveau de rémunération dernier point
j'ai entendu tout à l'heure que vous
étiez l'offre la moins coûteuse c'est
c'est un élément que vous nous avez vous
avez pé la connaissance la commission
d'enquête euh est-ce que on peut situer
justement ce qui fait que vous êtes
moins coûteux que les autres euh ce qui
pourrait dans ce caslà expliquer que le
choix soit porté sur vous malgré un
peut-être un taux de rémunération
relativement élevé
oui alors je je je vais vous faire une
réponse qui
euh
sera probablement trop global pour vous
satisfaire parce que pour aller dans le
détail euh des coûts
et du montage du financement qui est une
question que vous avez posé euh nous
souhaitons le faire dans des
conditions ultérieures
voilà puisque nous considérons que c'est
sont des aspects qui sont couverts par
le secret des affaires le montant total
des investissements c'est 650 millions
d'euros hein c'est c'est de c'est de cet
ordre là
pour pour pour le reste de
votre de votre
propos je je je ne suis pas sûr que en
fait quand on parle de PPP
comparable je ne suis pas totalement
convaincu que il y ait réellement des
PPP qui soit comparable en
fait la référence
habituel que nous avons pour les PPP et
sont très souvent des PPP je dirais
d'ordre
bâtimentaire où le risque technologique
est d'une nature je ne dis pas qu'il
n'existe pas mais il est d'une nature
très différente par rapport au au
risques technologiques que nous avons dû
assumer pour la construction du
dispositif
euh
euh ce dispositif en
fait nous avons
souigner ces caractéristiques je me
souviens qu'il y a eu une question sur
les exigences de l'État français
n'était-elles pas trop importante par
rapport à ce qui a pu se faire par
ailleurs en
Europe j'ai en tête peut-être une
exigence que nous n'avons pas
suffisamment souligné qui est euh le
fait que ce système est un système
totalement ouvert il est totalement
interopérable il est totalement conforme
à la législation européenne et de ce
point de vue le système français est le
seul et le premier en Europe à avoir
cette caractéristique car euh
ecomove n'est pas placé contrairement
par exemple à to collect mais également
à tous les autres opérateurs en Europe
de systèmes semblables dans une
position de
monopole le fait que le système soit
interopérable qu'il soit ouvert à des
sociétés tierces privées qui font
commerce de produits vers les
transporteurs crée une complexité
multiplie le nombre
d'acteurs force le la solution technique
à être très adaptative très ouverte dans
cette affaire il ne faut jamais perdre
de vue
que selon les prévisions qui sont faites
par l'État mais qui paraissent tout à
fait conforme à ce qu'on a observé
jusqu'à maintenant dans le nombre
d'enregistrement que l'on a sugéré
jusqu'au jusqu'à la l'annonce de la
suspension euh 80
%
des Red
des transporteurs seront en fait traités
par les sociétés habilité au télépéage
et non pas par la société ecomove qui
elle ne s'occupera de ce qu'on appelle
que les redevables non abonnés qui sont
donc plutôt des utilisateurs je dirais
occasionnels du réseau taxable et qui
donc ne font pas la démarche de
s'abonner auprès d'une société
spécialisée donc vous voyez cette cette
caractéristique ce niveau d'exigence de
l'État français mais qui ne fait queêtre
conforme à la législation européenne a
créé un environnement qui est tout à
fait spécifique à ce PPP
écotax est-ce qu'on peut répondre
monsieur courouril à la question de la
mise à disposition et et de la reporteur
sur le la question qu'elle a soulevé sur
la possibilité des sessions d'action
parce que je crois qu'on n pas eu de
réponse à ce
sujet beaucoup de questions sur le S
question de NOTAM plan social donc aussi
impatient que lui pour voà il y a a un
certain nombre de de de questions qui
sont restées sans réponse jusqu'à
présent alors euh j'en viens donc
effectivement à la question de la mise à
disposition
euh il y a donc pour nous une étape
importante qui est la mise à disposition
qui serait
théoriquement suivi de la mise en
service par l'État
donc la mise à disposition c'est l'étape
qui consiste à la remise par echomove du
système en bon état de fonctionnement
comment on vérifie qu'il y a un système
en bon état de fonctionnement par une
série de tests qui sont réalisés par
nous-même et par l'État il y a d'abord
ce qu'on appelle la VABF c'est-à-dire la
vérification d'aptitude au bon
fonctionnement cette étape constitue
dans une série de tests techniques qui
ont été réalisés conjointement par
l'État et parcomou et l'État a considéré
à l'issue de cette vérification c'était
quand ça alors ça s'est
déroulé c'est achevé le 8 novembrechev
le 8
novemb donc consid qu'il n'y avait pas
de défaut qui était susceptible de
retarder la mise à disposition et il y a
quelque chose de matérialisé un document
qui dit ça ou oui oui oui oui oui il y a
des il y a des courriers que nous
pourrons que pourons transmettre he
conformément au contrat l'état nous a
communiqué le le rapport final de ces
vérifications le 22 novembre dans lequel
l'État a souligné que euh le dispositif
est parfaitement conforme aux
prescriptions techniques fonctionnell et
légal applicable et que euh le prononcé
de laavabf euh euh aurait été fait dès
que les dispositif aurait euh été euh
homologué le dispositif à ce jour est
homologué donc nous attendons que l'État
euh finalise comme le prévoit le contrat
les étapes de vérification qui mènent à
la mise à
disposition alors voilà donc la babf
donc avec une lettre de l'État les
l'homologation et donc ce sont des
courriers et des documents qui nous sont
communiqués par les
laboratoires chargés de cette
homologation et et l'organisme
homologation c'est que dans le cadre du
système il y a des chaînes de traitement
notamment des chaînes de collectes des
chaînes de contrôle automatique et des
chaînes de contrôle
manuel qui font l'objet d'une démarche
d'homologation euh particulièrement des
certifications des équipements technique
et d'homologation des
chaînes tous les vérifications
nécessaires ont été réalisées par des
laboratoire agréé par les
cofc voir accrédité est accrédité par la
COFRAC voir agréé par l'État euh et les
livstar l'organisme d'homologation
accrédité par l'État il a émis ses avis
d'homologation pour tous les chaînes et
sur cette base l'état nous a communiqué
les certificats
d'homologation envie de vous dire
qu'est-ce qu'on attend pour faire cette
mise à disposition parce que ça vous
pénalise quand même ça de pas avoir une
mise à disposition officielle parce
qu'on comm payer qu'à partir de la mise
à disposition à ma
connaissance que je voulais traduire
dans l'exposé préliminaire tout à
l'heure en disant le système est prêt il
a subi tous les test et tous
les les les homologations nécessaires
pour que soit prononcé la VBF et c'est
effectivement l'étape que nous sommes en
train d'attendre de la part de l'État je
ré ma question question les 25000
facturations détaillées sur combien en
mois ou en anné pleine alors oui alors
je voilà alors je vais je vais revenir
là sur le sur la marche à blanc donc je
répondais à la à la question sur la V
sur la mise à disposition donc
aujourd'hui nous considérons c'est ce
qui m'a permis d'être aussi affirmatif
dans le propos préliminaire que le
système est prêt à
être réceptionné par l'État j'en déduis
que vous considérez qu'il n'y a pas de
retard de votre part qu'il n'y a pas de
retard par rapport
auour pas en retard c'était 18 mois au
départ hein le contrat quand même donc
il y a un petit peu de retard quand même
attendez oui ça c'est par rapport au
calendrier du contrat poser la question
par la DAT d'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
nous pouvons faire la mise à disposition
par l'État et nous attendons
effectivement que cette mise à
disposition soit prononcée mais la
marche
la marche Blanc avait été
prévue au moment où il y a eu de la part
de
l'État la date du 20 juillet qui avait
été reporté au 1er octobre de mise en
service et l'État a souhaité de façon à
parfaire le le système qu'il y ait
marche à blanc qui soit effectué je vous
rappelle d'ailleurs que dans le le
projet du 20 juillet il y avait pas de
March à blanc qui était prévu mais il y
avait une taxe à Alsace en Alsace et
cette t en Alsace a été supprimée par
l'État et a été remplacée par une marche
à blanc de façon à ce qu'il puisse y
avoir
euh de la part de l'État une observation
du fonctionnement du système alors ce
cette marche à blanc doit se dérouler
devait et doit se dérouler avec des
des
volontaires effectivement madame la
Présidente ce sont plutôt des
entreprises structurées qui ont
participé à la barche blanc mais il y a
également d'autres transporteurs qui ont
souhaité se préparer activement à
l'introduction de cette taxe qui ont
également été volontaire 10000 véhicules
ont participé cette parchat blanc je
vous ai dit ces 10000 véhicules ont sur
les 4 mois de March à blanc donné lieu à
10000 enregistrements de notre part de
de franchissement notamment de points de
tarification le dépouillement de ces
informations nous a permis d'établir
27000 euh alors liquidation facture
facture détaillé qui ont été
effectivement transmises et qui ont
donné lieu à des vérifications notamment
de la part des volontaires de la marche
à blanc c'était un des
retours positifs pour les transporteurs
de participer à cette marche à blanc je
crois qu'il serait bien que vous nous
donniez un modèle de ces factures entre
guillemets détaillé parce que justement
une des critiques c'est queil y a pas
beaucoup de détails sur ces factures et
que notamment pour une petite entreprise
une PME c'est absolument impossible de
vérifier quoi que ce soit alors le
contrat prévoit
que les factures détaillées peuvent être
transmis aux entreprises qui en font la
demande
euh voilà sur simple demande et transmis
sous forme papier ou sous forme
électronique autrement dit le système
normal c'est qu'on a juste un montant à
payer il y a pas de détail des des
passages à tel endroit ou et cetera si
on veut obtenir ça il faut le demander
mais on l'obtient et on l'obtient et ça
pas seulement dans la marche à blanc on
parle aussi après oui oui moi je parle
surtout après je parle surtout après la
structure de la facture était décidée
par l'État donc nous avons pris
exactement les spécifications de l'État
sur la structure de la facture et nous
avons implémenter les décisions pris par
l'État rien de plus et de moins le
transporteur pour pourra dans ce cadre
là avoir un détail de ces parcours mais
pourra même avoir un détail des points
de tarification qui ont été
franchis est-ce que j'ai répondu à votre
oui question très bien alors en ce qui
concerne le le site de ma il y a un
certain nombre de questions précises qui
ont été posées par Monsieur grodidier
et quel je souhaite pouvoir apporter des
précisions
euh tout d'abord un système existe un
système comparable qui est exploité en
régie qui qui est exploité en régie à
notre connaissance
non on peut simplement citer la Suisse
qui fait exploiter son système mais qui
est tout de même très différent sur le
plan technologique qu' fait exploiter
par son administration des douanes bon
c'est sans doute ce que vous appelez la
régie bien
sinon les autres systèmes Montt été
confié à des prestataires privés sous
des formes juridiques très
différentes pour les raisons je je pense
qui ont été évoqués longuement à
l'intérieur de cette commission c'est
pour des raisons de complexité de
développement technologique et avoir un
prestataire qui assure l'ensemble de la
responsabilité dans un cadre financier
très prédéfini je pense que c'est pour
les l'état une bonne
précaution alors en ce qui concerne le
site de mes prétropole monsieur
président mini a répondu tout à l'heure
sur les modalités
avec avec l'agglomération de M métropole
en ce qui concerne le coût social nous
avons
aujourd'hui honorer tous nos engagements
vis-à-vis du personnel et notamment le
personnel en CDI est aujourd'hui
toujours employé par par nous
effectivement alors ceci représente
pour 159 personnes qui aujourd'hui sont
employés en CDI sur un total de 193
personnes pour l'ensemble des
comov nous n'avons effectivement pas
donné suite au contrat qui était en CTD
et nous avons retardé l'embauche des
personnels complémentaires puisque nous
estimons que dans une phase
opérationnelle à terme c'estàd quand le
système fonctionnera il nécessitera un
effectif de 300 personnes
environ ce personnel d'ailleurs qui
devait être emembauché était
principalement affecté au centre de
traitement des anomalies vous
comprendrez qu'en absence de
fonctionnement du système donc en
absence d'anomalie on avait pas
d'occupation pour ce
personnel est-ce que j'ai répondu à peu
près à vos
questions
question a été mis en place
oui oui un un PRME mis en place euh euh
ve dire une une cellle quoi on a des
gens effectivement dont les CDD ont
interrompu qui se retrouvent aujourd'hui
avec pô emploi et certains en ayant
préalablement épuisé tous leurs droits
indemnisation contte tenu de la
perspective qui qui soffrait à eux donc
je voulais savoir quelle mesure
d'accompagnement ces public là donc on
me dit que c'est une
soixantaine donc
ça50 euh euh font-ils l'objet
actuellement et quels sont aujourd'hui
euh indépendamment des CDI on avait un
certain nombre de personnes qui étaient
stagiaires de la formation
professionnelle et qui avaient vocation
être embauché à court terme donc
manifestement elle le seront pas et et
est-ce qu'il y a avec les services de
l'état des solutions d'attente qui sont
mise en place ou est-ce que euh bah en
l'absence de de de date de et de
calendrier précis ces personnes
retombent dans le droit commun sur le
CDD j'explique le CDD a été pris pour la
phase de enregistrement et donc le
moment queistrement a été en fait
suspendu nous avons terminé l'activité
avec les CDD et tout les cas c'est en
CDD et les gens connaît très bien la
durée déterminée de de cet embouchement
sous les CDD ça été le choix pour la
part de de la formation euh nous avons
misise en place un solution avec les pô
d'emploi qui prévoit un un
accompagnement pour tous les personne
une formation euh chez pour l'emploi
à à la fin de trouver un nouvel emploi
dans la dans la région de la
loireen le problème se POS j'ai la
confirmation qu'il n'y a aucun
DISP que les personnes retombent dans
dans le droit commun et que même celles
sont indemnité donc retombe dans le
droit commun parfois même de laass ou du
RSA donc c'est c'est confirmation qui
est fait il y a pas d'autres dispositifs
alors qu'on en est on en connaît lorsque
des des opérations de de de reconversion
sont nécessité par des restructurations
euh notamment lié à des décisions de
l'État ce qui n'est pas le cas ici ce
qui mérite quand même d'être souligné
donc il n'y a rien d'autre que le droit
commun par ailleurs je souhaiteraiis des
réponses sur les contacts qui auraient
pu être établis avant l'annonce
officielle de la suspension et quelle
relation avait eu avec l'État pour
estimer les coûts mesurer les
conséquences et
cetera alors sur les contacts voilà je
vais compléter la réponse
pour le sénateur grd en fait euh je
rpare le CDD était était prévu pour
accompagner la phase du pic
d'enregistrement qui
allait se compléter dans les prévisions
fin décembre et donc comme cette phlà
après la suspension euh n'a pu eu Liu
euh il a été forcément euh de ne pouvoir
pas renouvellerer ces contrat là et pour
autant pour la formation il avait euh il
était prévu d'embaucher comme Monsieur
Corny venait de le dire euh une 6antaine
de personnes en vieu de de la mise en
service de l'exploitation et ça
effectivement euh n'est pas possible car
à ce moment on a aucune date pour mise
en service et voir même pour la mise à
disposition euh pour revenir à à vos
questions euh en en effet nous sommes
été euh surpris comme comme vous nous
avons été surpris comme vous euh par
l'annonce de suspension de l'écotaxe euh
car aucune communication
préalable n'avait n'avait été faite
aomov et donc et donc donc vous l'avez
appris par la presse vous aussi oui au
même en même en même temps et d'après et
d'après aucune mission d'accompagnement
au niveau social a été
établi ni a été
démandé in conséquence de l'État quand
même rajouter quelque chose oui on peut
préciser d'ailleurs
que nous avons des contacts qui
continuent avec la mission tarification
qui sont principalement des contacts
techniques mais nous avons pour
l'instant aucun contact aucune
négociation engagée pour le le futur et
l'avenir des des quelques jours VO des
quelques semaines qui
viennent juste pour vous demander
d'ailleurs quels sont quels étaient vos
conseils au moment de la conclusion du
contrat vous aviez des conseils
avocat vous aviez des j'aimerais que
vous nous disiez les les les conseils
qui sont intervenus de votre côté
et également que vous précisiez quels
étaient vos contacts au niveau de l'État
je voudais savoir avec qui vous aviez
langue comme on dit oui la mission
tarification de la DGTM qui est notre
contract oui et leses et les douanes
peut-être vous donner des des
renseignements précis
sur cette cette deuxème partie de votre
question je reviendrai sur la première
concernant les
conseils donc nos les interlocuteurs
réguliers des comov dans le cadre du
contrat de
partenariat ont été donc au sein du
ministère de l'Écologie du Développement
durable et l'énergie les membres de la
mission de la tarification du service
donc de l'administration générale de la
stratégie dirigée par Monsieur Antoine
maocor qui était assisté de ses adjoints
Olivier cis et Madame Annie corille pour
pour la direction générale des douanes
et droits
indirects donc cette mission de la
tarification
elle dépend de la Direction générale des
infrastructures des transports et de la
mer qui est dirigé par Monsieur
bursau et notre interlocuteur régulier
au titre du contrat était monsieur
maocor et est toujours monsieur
maocor comme le rappelait monsieur
Cornil
euh en ce qui concerne les conseils qui
ont assisté
euh autostrade
euh lors du montage de
l'opération il y avait deutsge Bank qui
était le conseil en financement euh
marche en ce qui concerne la partie des
assurances euh catricom qui est une
société de conseil en logistique euh en
formation du réseau euh de distribution
euh des équipements embarqués et d'une
façon plus générale en ce qui concerne
la
documentation de
l'offre il y avait price water house s
Cooper qui est le conseil audit du
modèle financier et quiit charge
d'établir pour le compte d'autostrade le
mémoire comptable et fiscal qui a été
demandé par les termes de la
consultation en conseil juridique il y
avait Becker
McKenzie
wilkyar a assisté également ce qui
concerne la mise en place de la partie
très spécifique du financement de projet
et puis enfin Mazard qui euh a assisté
autostrade pour l'audit des systèmes et
des processus qui était également une
exigence demandée par l'État dans la
réponse à l'appel d'offre voilà de façon
très précise et limitative les conseils
j'aimerais répondre à des questions qui
avaient ét
justement exaement la session des des
sessions c'est le contrat euh et
spécifiquement dans l'Annex 3 36 qui
prévoit que
euh que les titulaires donc puisse donc
puisse aider
jusque à 30 % euh
du du montant total de de la
participation
actionnaire
depuis depuis la signature du contrat et
le contrat prévoit également
que après le descend une session àti
peut-être faite par les stionnaires
jusqu'à jusqu'à atteindre la majorité je
m'explique bien euh pourvu que les
actionnaires maintiennent le la
majorité la majorité du capital social
et la session attire euh ne nécessite
pas d'une autorisation de l'État mais si
euh cette session envisage euh la perte
de la majorité là l'État doit autoriser
au préalable cette session et l'État a
tous les instrument pour s'assurer que
cette disposition soit euh effectivement
gardée place donc pour revenir à une
autre question euh si et d'autres pays
dans d'autres pays l'État a jamais
réalisé le gouvernement a réalisé un
propre un système pareil je dirais qu'à
notre connaissance non je vous euh men
l'exemple euh dans l'Autriche l'État
c'est à confié euh ce
euh ce projet ce système à une société
dans le cas choisi autostrade et après
après sa réalisation donc une fois que
tous les risques de construction ont été
euh porté par le partenaire privé l'État
a racheté le système à notre
connaissance c'est la dans le dans la
Slovaquie dans la Suisse en Suisse
seulement seulement la Suisse mais le
système est totalement différent car se
bas sur des viget
le rapporteur oui on a justement
beaucoup parlé d'évolution du système et
et la circulation mais on relativement
peu évoqué en tout cas aujourd'hui les
reports de circulation donc euh je
suppose que c'est l'état français oou
est-ce que vous avez participé au choix
du réseau taxable ou est-ce que c'est
vraiment que les critères parce que
certains esprits chagrin disent
autostrade c'est italien et comme par
hasard on peut continuer de traverser
toute la France quand on on vient de
l'Italie sans rentrer sur le réseau
taxable ceci étant dit S sous forme
peut-être un peu de boutade il reste que
les études qui ont été faites euh
tendent à penser que il va y avoir un
report de trafic assez rapidement de ce
réseau taxable finalement vers le le
réseau autoroutier concédé euh et que
donc le réseau routier au concéder va
voir ses recettes augmenter sans pour
autant participer en rien finalement à
cette écot tax et au au bénéfice qu'on
en attend justement pour le réinjecter
dans des infrastructures ferroviaires et
cetera et cetera donc ça ça a pas été
pris du tout en
compte a été déterminé à la suite d'un
certain nombre de simulations qui ont
été fait par les services de l'État
notamment les services spécialisés ca
les organes d'études de l'État qui ont
simuler les reports à partir des relevés
qu'ils avaient de trafic et des
hypothèses d'hypothèses qu'ils ont fait
bon je pense que ce sont des services
qui sont très spécialisés et très
habitués à faire ce genre de travail et
kovou n'a absolument pas participé à ces
travaux c'était pour nous une donnée
dans la réponse alors en ce qui concerne
les reports sur autoroute euh on n pas
de commentaire à
faire c'est un fait ce que vous dites
sauf sauf peut-être par rapport à la
rémunération par variable vous nous avez
dit tout à l'heure c'était fonction de
la montée en charge ou j'imagine de la
descente en
charge mais on a dit que ces éléments là
ser évoqués à un autre moment ce que
vous dites c'est un
fait c'est réel et et même pour ce qui
concerne
écom pourrait être une révision à la
baisse un risque d'entreprise que que
nous avons pris dans dans notre
projet j'ai j'ai dit une phrase dans mon
introduction
qui j'ai dit que toutes les nous avions
pris tous les risques y compris la
plupart de ce relatif aux évolutions de
l'environnement pendant la période
d'exploitation ça recouvre ce type de de
risque l'état nous a transféré ce type
de
risque vous pouvez pourtant pas être
complètement altruiste ça j'y crois
pas en tout cas vousirz
pasier 2014 là vousz pas encore envoyer
de facture ecove à l'état qu' pas la la
mise qu'est-ce que je dis 1er janvier
bien vous n'avez pas facturé on est bien
d'accord parisque la mise à disposition
n'a pas eu n'a pas eu lieu voilà
Monsieur capo canellaa avait demandé la
la parole merci madame la Présidente je
vais revenir sur la question des délis
du du
calendrier pour comprendre le le
phénomène de
report en clair qu'est-ce qui a conduit
à ce délai avant la décision de
suspension si on prend une référence par
exemple qui est la nomination du nouveau
gouvernement de l'actuel gouvernement
qu'est-ce qui a engendré le fait que
jusque à la fin de l'année on n'avait
pas pu faire démarrer le système je
parle bien avant la décision de
suspension en clair est-ce qu'il y a eu
des changements techniques qui relèvent
de l'état des demandes nouvelles où
est-ce que vous étiez vous en retard
est-ce qu'il y avait un problème
d'enregistrement voilà il y a une assez
longue chronique là une assez longue
séquence et nos concitoyens n'ont pas
forcément compris pourquoi tout ce
temps-là avait été perdu donc première
question c'est c'est sur ce ce point
précis deuxème chose tout à l'heure on a
parlé de l'
l'interopérabilité et de
l'interprétation que la France a pu
faire de la réglementation européenne ou
peut-être si j'ai bien compris d'une
forme de volonté d'être bon élève en
clair est-ce que ceci s traduit par un
contrat beaucoup plus rigide beaucoup
plus exigeant en France et est-ce que ça
a une conséquence sur le coût parce que
on reproche souvent à l'administration
française faire trop de de
surinterpréter R entation européenne
est-ce qu'on est dans ce dans ce type de
de point dernière question sur les
portiques euh j'ai pas bien saisi tout à
l'heure vos réponses là-dessus je
comprends que les portiques sont
nécessaires sinon il aurait fallu
gladoine et beaucoup plus de de moyens
humains pour faire des contrôles bon
est-ce que c'est
bien la réponse que vous souhaitez
apporter à ça parce que c'est vra que la
question des portiques euh donne de
votre technique un côté désué alors que
vous nous dites que vous êtes à la
pointe avec un système satellitaire au
top et que
l'Allemagne finalement a des a des vieux
systèmes bon voilàon mais pour autant en
est-ce qu'on pouvait pas réellement se
passer un peu plus éportique ce qui
d'ailleurs contribue pas à la popularité
de de l'écotaxe et puis enfin
globalement j'arrête là-dessus je vis
dire ma frustration parce que vous
sortez d'un dialogue compétitif vous
avez gagné et j'ai le sentiment que vous
n'arrivez pas à nous dire en 5 ou 10
phrases qu'est-ce qui fait que votre
système est bon qu'est-ce qui fait qu'il
fallait le mettre en place et qu'est-ce
qui fait que vous étiez au point j'ai
toujours pas compris à l'issue de plus
de 2 heur d'audition et je m'étonne et
je voudrais vous tendre la perche pour
que vous nous disiez un peu en
conclusion voilà pourquoi votre offre
était la bonne en quelques mots claire
et intelligible par tous on l'a toujours
pas cette
réponse bien alors sur sur ce qui
concerne
les les jalons dans le temps euh il y
avait donc un un premier jalon
contractuel qui était le mois de juillet
13 à cette à ce moment-là avec l'État
nous avons estimé qu'il y avait un
certain nombre de dispositions à la fois
technique et administratives qui étaient
à
parfaire l'État a je l'ai signalé tout à
l'heure par exemple modifié le
le le périmètre puisque la taxe POS
lourd alsacienne a été supprimée
remplacé par la marche à blanc donc nous
avonsu et a estimé que les tests
n'étaient pas à ce moment-là
satisfaisant et donc il y a une décision
deorter au 1er octobre au 1er
octobre il y avait effectivement vous
l'avez
souligné le problème des enregistrements
les enregistrements étaient ouverts
avaient été ouvert dans le courant de
l'été et nous observions à ce moment-là
une très
faible croissance ou participation de la
part des transporteurs à
s'enregistrer c'était absolument
indispensable qu'on ait un volume
suffisant de de véhicules enregistrés si
nous voulions que le
système puisse être lancé qu'il y ait un
phénomène d'entraînement
bon pour citer quelques chiffres nous
sommes sur des hypothèses où nous allons
avoir 400000 véhicules enregistrés au
titre des
abonnés et à la fin du mois d'août je
travaille de mémoire mais nous en avie
peut-être 25000 25000 donc nous étions
très très loin de l'objectif
qui qui était
raisonnable bon ce ce
constat on en a fait part à l'état et il
y avait on a considéré qu'il y avait une
chose qui était absolument nécessaire
pour que le système se lance dans de
bonnes conditions c'est que la date de
mise en service soit clairement
affiché que les décrets soi soi pris et
donc c'est à ce moment-là que l'État a
décidé
de différer au 1er janvier avec un
décret qui est paru est-ce que vous
pouvez me le 5 octobre 5 octobre le
décret fixant la date au 1er janvier a
été pris par l'État et nous avons
d'ailleurs observé une
accélération des
enregistrements pour vous donner un
chiffre
aujourd'hui nous en sommes à
1800 véhicule
enregistré dans nos fichiers équipé de
dispositifs et qui serait donc tout à
fait opérationnel en cas de mise en
place sur
800000 sur puisquon dit qu'il y a 600000
camions français et 200000 étrangers oui
alorstrangers ne sont pas obligés d'être
prêt de la taxe que l'étranger é
der ous les
moment estimation qui nimpa pas la démar
système les les Français sont évidemment
les les relevables obligés àavoir la les
boîtiers dedans le
véhicule mais moi moi je comprends pas
très bien ce que vous venez de dire
parce que en plus j'ai eu le sentiment
les chiffres qui m'ont été communiqués
c'est plutôt les étrangers qui au départ
sont venus en nombre il se sont
enregistrés en nombre donc je comprends
pas très bien votre votre remarque
là la remarque c'est donc que il y a une
obligation pour les véhicules français
et les véhicules étrangers ne sont
obligés de s'équiper d'un équipement
embarqué que lorsqu'ils utilisent ce
réseau taxable bien
effectivement votre source est bonne ce
sont dans un premier temps les étrangers
qui se sont inscrits en
premier ça c'est un des bénéfices
d'avoir eu recours à des sociétés TPH
qui travaillent au niveau de l'Europe et
qui ont d'abord ciblé les véhicules
étrangers pour garnir leur
fichierers dans dans une logique
commerciale depuis la situation s'est
inversée et nous avons maintenant dans
les chiffres récents que je vous ai
donné une majorité de
Français bien évidemment depuis
l'annonce de la suspension
euh de
l'écotaxe voilà les on peut pas
reprocher au transporteur de ne pas
venir s'enregistrer mais il faut quand
même noter que 190000 c'est peu par
rapport aux 800000 alors c'est ce que je
voulais vous dire c'est que quand vous
quand vous prenez euh les parcs 800000
c'est le nombre de véhicules total
maximum quand vous prenez les véhicules
qui euh ne sortent pas parce qu'ils sont
en en révision et tout ça ceux qui sont
en cours d'immatriculation et surtout
tous les non abonnés qui ne passent pas
par cette procédure
d'enregistrement qui passe par une autre
procédure et bien effectivement nous
arrivons plutôt à un chiffre cible que
nous avons estimé aux alentours de
400000 pour les
abonnés excusez-moi j'ai perdu le fil de
oui c'est Mo qui vous écoute rép les
abonnés mais vousenez dire
comp non non non non les nonabonnés euh
passent par un autre circuit qui est le
circuit de distribution mis en place par
ecomove et où euh quand il y a des un
déplacement ponctuel à faire ils
viennent s'équiper ponctuellement du
dispositif donc on était pas dans le
processus d'enregistrement qui avait été
ouvert au mois de juillet pour les
abonnés uniquement moi simplement ce qui
me choque je vous le dis franchement
hein il y a quand vous dites on est prêt
moi je peux comprendre que on dit on est
après parce que la technique marche il y
a aussi quand même que on a les boîtiers
embarqués dans les camions sinon ça sert
à rien et aujourd'hui vous on n est pas
là on y est
pas absolument ouii tout à faitoui ça
n'a rien à voir avec ça na rien à voir
avec la mise à
disposition ce que je vous ai dit c'est
qu'on était prêt pour la mise à
disposition voilà c'est une précision
qui est quand même
importante
alors moi je pense que que votre qu'il
faut d'autant plus ça prendre en compte
que quand on va refixer une
date pour la remise en service de de
l'écotaxe il faudra tenir compte de ces
délais mais bon ok moi j'entends tout
simplement je vous trouve pas très
pardonnez-moi d'être un peu provocatrice
mais c'est peut-être notre rôle la
rapporteur et et moi-même je je vous
trouve pas exigeant sur cette mise à
disposition voilà vous vous attendez
tranquillement que finalement elle
arrive finalement à la demande de l'État
moi j'ai envie même pour vous provoquer
un peu de vous dire mais dans quelles
conditions l'État pourrait pas vous
imposer des pénalités à à ces délais qui
traînent qui traînent moi je je je je
vous demande là vraiment de de nous dire
quand même quelle est quelle est votre
position je vous trouve pas moi dans
votre position il me
semble connaissant un tout petit peu
quand même le monde des affaires que
j'exigerai de l'État que cette mise à
disposition se fe on a bien compris que
c'est différent de la mise en service
mais la mise à disposition ça permet à
un moment donné de fermer le j'allais
dire fermer le banc hein sur le contrat
PPP et d'y voir un peu plus clair parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez pas facturé
vous avezf c'est quand même une
situation complètement ubuesque quand
même hein je je je pense que je partage
tout à fait votre opinion et bon je va
prendre votre marque comme un conseil
non non non non mais je vous trouve très
gentil je trouve très gentil donc c'est
pour ça que moi je cherche cette
gentillesse en fait une part de
responsabilité que vous avez quand même
dans ce retard moi j'en suis convaincu
quand même vous en avez forcément une
c'est pas ben oui si quand même il doit
y en avoir une parce que sinon il y a
longtemps que vous auriez exigé ça je
pense que le contrat que vous avez quand
même épluché vous protège forcément tous
les risques pour une entreprise j'ai
beaucoup de
mal si si je peux préciser en effet nous
avons demandé à l'état de finaliser au
plus vite les activités vous l'z demandé
comment comment vous avez fait une
lettre vous avez fait un courrier vous
avez fait il y a rien il y a rien c'est
ça qui est extraordinaire vous attendez
les uns et les autres enfin on verra
bien on va auditionner aussi l'état et
on posera les mêmes questions hein bon
voilà mais c'est quand même assez assez
incroyable que ça que ça traîne comme ça
les sommes en jeux sont quand même
importante moi je suis la commission des
finances comme vous vous le savez
puisque j'ai eu l'honneur de vous
auditionner déjà dans le cadre de la
commission des des finances ENF c'est
quand même des sommes importantes et
donc il est normal que on se préoccupe
de de de ces questions parce que à un
moment donné il va falloir faire les
comptes quand même il va falloir faire
les additions ou les soustractions hein
si oui une petite réflexion bon chacun
d'entre nous n'est pas naïf quand on a
été ou dans l'entreprise
ou responsable dans les collectivités on
sait bien quand on a été en face de nous
et qui qui veut rien faire il fait rien
bon qui résiste et vous pouvez toujours
le mettre en demeure on est quand même
en état d'infériorité si j'ose dire bon
ça c'est le premier point le deuxième
quand même ça m'intéresserait parce que
nous collectivité euh on est aussi des
créanciers potentiels h des on on on a
les départements oui donc moi je connais
la somme que depuis un certain temps
j'attends et que je ne vois toujours pas
et je me demande si je peux pas me
retourner contre quelqu'un alors je
parle pas contre vous mais contre l'État
par exemple et et et et à quel niveau
pour dire j'ai inscrit dans mes budgets
depuis des années déjà parce que ça fait
quand même X fois qu'on reporte des
sommes à percevoir et comme rien ne se
passe les sommes n'arrivent pas bon et
et et je peux estimer que j'ai des
dépenses des usures des pr et cetera
donc ça m'intéresserait quand même de
savoir quand ça va commencer et comment
ça va commencer alors bien sûr ça dépend
d'une décision de l'État euh c'est bien
évident euh mais il va bien falloir la
déclencher aussi d'une manière ou d'une
autre cette décision et et tant que vous
ne bougez pas enfin tant que vous bougez
pas tant que l'État ne bouge pas par
rapport à vous si j' dire il bougera pas
par rapport à nous donc l'enjeu il est
pas seulement excusez-moi de de de ne
pas seulement penser à vous mais de
penser aussi à d'autres comme
collectivité il est aussi à d'autres
niveaux puis y avait la fite aussi je
crois d'autres qui sont intéressés à ce
genre de sujet ça c'est une remarque
deuxième point euh je crois que les
camions je sais pas si vous l'avez
évoqué mais j'avais vu des transporteur
qui avait beaucoup de véhicules et qui
s'était équipé déjà depuis longtemps et
il m'avait dit que ça leur coûtait à peu
près 350 € par véhicule peut-être j'ai
mal entendu que c'est ancien donc quand
vous avez 200 300 ou 500 véhicules ça
finit par faire des sommes alors vous
direz il vaut mieux acheter l'équipement
et ne pas payer la taxe que d'acheter
l'équipement et de payer la taxe enfin
quand même tous ceux qui ont acheté
longtemps à l'avance des équipements euh
parce qu'ils ont été de bons citoyens
euh se retrouvent avec des
investissements qui sont aussi
inutilisés inutilisable ce qui est ce
qui est pas très normal non plus c'est
un investissement qui serait peut-être
mieux euh mis ailleurs dans la
production plutôt que de dormir dans des
camions hein alors est-ce que 350 €
c'est une somme qui euh vous dit quelque
chose non un transporteur pour s'équiper
il paye he oui alors l'équipement est
remis et remis gratuitement mais je
pense que le transporteur fait allusion
au coût
d'installation électrique de cet
équipement dans ses véhicules c'estàdire
ça passe à l'atelier ou c'est donc c'est
ces écous là qui sont qui sont externes
à notre à nous mais qui qui sont dans
alors madame j'ai j'ai parfaitement
entendu et reçu votre votre
remarque ce que je veux vous répondre
c'est que cette situation elle est elle
date de 1er janvier puisque c'était au
1er janvier
que le système pouvait être mis à
disposition et éventuellement mis en
service par l'État donc nous
avons la mise en service au 1 janvier au
1er janvier oui vous voulez dire que la
mise à disposition était en novembre
novembre oui c'est ça 20 novembre oui
oui c'est ça donc nous sommes dans nous
sommes dans un cas de figure qui est
relativement récent nous avons
effectivement voulu laisser passer les
l'échéan de jeananvier la commission
Sénator il y aura une réponseé il y aura
ça bougera avant la fin du rapport de de
la
commission alors Monsieur Grier je
obstiné mais j'ai pas réponse à toutes
mes questions bon si vous m'avez bien je
sair j'ai bien compris bien dit que il
n'y avait eu aucun contact avec l'État
dans les jours ou les heures qui ont
précédé l'annonce de cette suspension
pour estimer éventuellement au moins les
coûts financiers et sociaux de cette
décision si vous m'avez bien indiqué
qu'il n'y a aucun contact avec l'État
aujourd'hui en dehors de la relation de
droit commun avec Pôle emploi
sur la réparation aujourd'hui des
conséquences sociales de cette décision
et aucun contact non plus sur une
définition à court terme euh euh d'un
d'un de perspective euh euh et et
précise euh sur votre reprise d'activité
m'avez pas répondu à la question de
savoir s'il y avait eu entre vous-même
et l'État ou le gouvernement euh depuis
juin 2012 donc depuis l'installation du
gouvernement des demandes euh
d'éclaircissement ou d'explication euh
sur tel ou tel point euh de la procédure
ou de sa mise en œuvre euh qui ont
suscité des polémiques postérieurement à
l'annonce de la suspension mais jamais
antérieurement alors est-ce qu'il y
avait des inquiétudes des demandes au
moins d'explications qui s'étaient
exprimé de la part de l'État pendant
cette période bon je j'ai répondre euh
je pars de la dernière non monsieur
jamais l'état nous n nous nous s adressé
par écrit ou oralement aucune inquiétude
aucune demande aucune éclaircissement
sur les modalités de passation de la
procédure je vous rappelle il a été déjà
dit euh avant à plusieurs reprises que
le Conseil d'État a eu la possibilité de
juger sur le fond pas seulement sur le
euh sur la forme sur le fond de cette
procédure sur sur des motivations très
très articulées et il a établi que la
procédure a été parfaitement régulière
donc on aurait été très très surpris si
l'état nous aurait faite
ok quelqu soit de remarques sur sur la
procédure de passation du contrat
premièrement pour répondre à aux autres
questions je je vous confirme que nous
nous n'avons eu aucun contact avec
l'État préalablement à la suspension qui
portait sur le sujet de la suspension
nous sommes toujours nous avons donné
notre disponibilité à à à l'état à
trouver des aménagements euh pour gérer
la situation de la suspension mais nous
ne nous sommes nous n'avons pas été euh
pour le moment invité à une négociation
est-ce
que a une
information qu'il y avait d'autres
questions monsieur vous aviez redemandé
la parole euh non madame la Présidente
mais puisque vous m'y invitez juste
c'est pour que vous nous redisiez en
quelques mots qu'est-ce qui fait qu'une
technologie qui repose sur des porties
qui était vraiment une technologie de
pointe et qu'est-ce qui fait que votre
offre de voilà était vraiment l'offre à
retenir pour l'intérêt de l'État dans
les circonstances qui étaient celle de
la
consultation à l'époque voilà oui je je
reviens sur le point spécifique que vous
avez abordé qui est le système de
contrôle automatique et c'estes
superstructure très visible sur le
réseau routier bon d'abord je je je
confirme tout à fait ce qui a été dit
par mon collègue Bti boya précédemment
c'està-dire que dans tous les systèmes
de taxation nationaux qui existent ce
type de contrôle automatique existe
partout si vous allez en Allemagne vous
verrez sur le réseau routier ces porti
d'ailleurs beaucoup plus imposants en
Allemagne qu'il ne le sont dans notre
solution en
France c'est quelque chose qui est
systématiquement déployé pourquoi parce
que
au-delà au-delà des moyens humains qui
seraiit rendu nécessaire si on voulait
contrôler l'ensemble du trafic assujetti
à la taxe qui peut circuler sur le
riseseau routier taxé chaque jour dans
un réseau routier français fort de 15000
km de route taxé au-delà de ce simple
problème de ressources humaines qui est
déjà un problème extrêmement important
en terme de coût cont tenu de la durée
d'exploitation envisagée du système il y
a aussi un simple
problème de possibilité je dirais à la
fois technique
et acceptable au plan de la sécurité du
déplacement des usagers
ou du travail des agents de contrôle
pour pouvoir faire le contrôle des
redevables comment peut-on imaginer euh
que des agents euh vont procéder à des
interpellations euh de véhicues qui ne
seraiit pas en règle euh qui circule euh
de nuit comme de jour euh sur euh le
réseau euh aux vitesse euh autorisée euh
comment peut-on imaginer qu'on va aller
arrêter un poids lourd étranger qui va
euh traverser euh euh la France puisque
vous savez que la France est un pays de
transit important en terme de transport
de marchandise en Europe qui va
traverser la France en une nuit en
utilisant pour parti le réseau
autoroutier pour parti le réseau gratuit
qui demain sera taxé et comment peut-on
imaginer qu'on va garantir la sécurité
des agents comment interpeller un camion
qui roule et qui arrive comme ça
brutalement et comment va-t-on assurer
l'équité du dispositif s'il n'y a pas un
système de lutte contre la fraude qui
soit parfaitement efficace et qui soit
parfaitement équitable à la fois pour
les transporteurs français et les
transporteurs étrangers voilà la
problématique je pense qui a conduiti
l'état à prescrire ce système de
contrôle et à
nouveau cela a déjà été dit mais
la consultation de l'État que ça soit
dans sa forme initiale ou à forciuie
dans sa forme finale était extrêmement
prescriptive en terme
de fonctionnalité du système donc euh je
ne sais pas ce qu'il en a été pour les
concurrents d'autostrade pendant la
compétition mais
euh en ce qui nous concerne nous avons
suivi les prescriptions du CAH des
charges de l'État
et ça n'est pas notre rôle que de porter
un jugement sur ces prescriptions mais
euh nous pouvons considérer quand même
que ce qui a été prescrit en terme de
système de contrôle était raisonnable eu
égard aux objectifs de contrôle d'
redevable le système n'a pas vocation
à j'allais dire attraper 100 % des
redevable dans ce cas-là le coût aurait
été trop important le système a
propension
à je
dirais verbaliser
89 % de mémoire c'est notre objectif de
performance en ce qui concerne les
véhicules qui viendrai à être en fraude
il faut bien avoir en tête que le
système étant basé sur un équipement
embarqué à bord du véhicule puisque on
mesure la distance
parcourue si le véhicule embarqué par
définition n'est pas équipé de cet
équipement ou que cet équipement est
rendu inopérant et bien le véhicule lui
se déplace gratuitement donc il est
absolument indispensable et sur des très
grandes quantités de véhicule encore une
fois circulant nuit et jour quelles que
soient les conditions météorologiques de
pouvoir de pouvoir assurer une détection
correcte de la
fraude voilà je pense que nous arrivons
au terme de de cette première audition
comme nous avons dit nous en aurons une
deuxième sur les questions
particulièrement financière nous aurons
pense que nous avons la volonté madame
le rapporteur et moi-même d'aller vous
voir aussi à mes hein je pense ça sera
utile que nous nous déplacions que nous
allions voir un peu le fonctionnement de
de tout ça et je vais donc proposer à à
Madame clè à notre rapporteur de
peut-être faire un petit point à ce
stade de cette conclusion de cette
première
réunion non ce serait difficile de faire
un point une synthèse parce que de
multiples sujets ont été abordés et
certains n'ont pas été creusés pour les
raisons que qu'on qu'on sa'est tous ici
he de de
confidentialité et de couverture par le
secret commercial d'un certain nombre
des des données
euh il est vrai malgré je suis restée
surprise du nombre de données couverte
par ce secret commercial puisque
l'objectif d'un PPP est quand même
d'optimiser les finances publiques et
que là en l'occurrence le citoyen
français moyen n'a aucun moyen mais
absolument aucun moyen de contrôler
justement si ce contrat a a ou n'a pas
optimisé l'argent et le fonctionnement
de des finances publiques on va le
regarder pour eux j'espère qu'on pourra
les en rassurer après donc en tout état
de cause merci de l'ensemble des
réponses et effectivement on aura
l'occasion de se revoir assez rapidement
pour creuser justement tous ces aspects
qu'on n pas pu creuser de façon publique
merci beaucoup merci à tout le
monde voilà vous avez donc pu suivre les
premières auditions la quête sénatoriale
sur la société eove tout de suite la
suite de nos programmes sur Public
Sénat